you
uh mr chair i have a question in terms
of you know
some
bills
public wanted to be at the exact
committee
uh
an executive session
uh to see how will they know
some bills that they were interested in
how we debate and what we do
just just thinking about because i got
calls for a couple of bills and i wanted
to let you know you could you could
certainly pass that on to them okay
if you're aware of a hearing that
they're interested in past that
not the hearing for exact sections but i
mean if you know from the hearing yeah
that they wanted to come to the exact
section okay you can certainly pass on
to them there's nothing secret about
what we're doing i know it's just that
uh timing
it's just the uh
the notice
for executive sessions does not have to
be in the calendar okay yeah
just so they asked me so i can
articulate and if i'm aware
and it lines up i'll mention it that
they're coming up okay great that will
be yeah i'll give you a list of ones
that uh i got calls for okay
thank you
to ms van
gaal
oh
sorry good job
okay we're going to open the hearing
this morning on house bill
1070 which is relative to default
budgets and official ballot
jurisdictions
representative baum you're going to open
the bill for us
you want to introduce the bill i mean
thank you mr chairman and honorable
members of municipal and county
i'm ralph baume hillsborough district
20 town of litchfield
uh and
i believe passed out testimony to
everybody
and
the reason for the municipal
official ballot law was that town did
not have a facility big enough to hold
regular town or school district meetings
one downtown i know of had meetings in
multiple locations with tv hookup
between locations even that was not
enough so this law came into being
allowing everyone the opportunity to
vote
this bill is common sense if the
governing body reduces something in
their proposed operating budget in other
words the selectmen or school board they
must make the same reductions in the
default
when this law was first passed in 1995
the default budgets were always lower
than the proposed operating budget but
after a while certain associations and
lawyers figure out a way by using the
wording of the law to manipulate the
default budget to make it higher than
the operating budget to ensure that the
budget will pass
but that was not the intent of the law
if you read the section 4013
roman 11 dash c
the wording of the second ballot
the second session valid question
concerning operating budget shall be as
follows
and if you read it and should this
article be defeated the default budget
shall be which is the same but then it
says or the governing body may hold one
special meeting in accordance with 4013
10 and 16 to take up the issue of
revived operating budget only so you can
see the intent was
the default would be lower if the
default was higher then why would
anybody
then why would this be in the law if the
article was defeated what governing body
would ask for a special meaning if they
got more
money what school districts are what
school districts are doing to follow the
law is for example not needing three
teachers they are removed from the
proposed operating budget but left in
the default if the teacher's contract
says they will fund clubs and sports
stipends for a total of 20k but never
spent more than 15 you guessed that the
operating budget will be 15 but the
default will be 20. on the town side if
every other year the town buys two
police cruisers but then won the next
year the year with the one we'll have
two in the default etc etc
for example this year my school district
the proposed operating budget is 23
million 766 000 while the default is 24
million 184 thousand
how do you think the people will vote
also the vote
luckily this i can say luckily but we
had the snowstorm friday so this was
moved we had a deliberative session last
saturday
and sure enough
the t the school board
did not recommend
this budget
5-0 against it of course they wanted to
fail so they get more money with the
default which was not the intent of the
law
also i
i was just looking at to propose bill
and for example
on line 23
the rsa 197 thing was crossed out that
should not have been i don't know how i
missed that but anyway
um
but i'll
available for any questions
any questions for the representative
from the committee
yes representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um this particular rsa we've been
talking about for several years in a row
giving little nudges here and there
i was um
wondering if you can
explain to me how line nine which is the
new language that you're putting in
uh works with line 18 the definition of
contracts
which means the contracts previously
approved
so you might have a contract in your
that stops
in your proposed budget but in here the
contract it means
in the default is what was previously
approved so you're still going to have
that empty bucket bucket of money aren't
you
no because
i was always my argument when i was on
the school board because the default
they said well the contract says i said
then aren't we breaking the law with the
proposed operating budget
so the argument being
uh well number of teachers that's
usually not in the contract but
but
stipends are but the stipends in the
contract say we've got to pay this much
if
you know but they always put the amount
total amount so
the number of teachers for example is
not in the contract and and i don't
think that's an issue if if you're
on the school board or or
selectmen and you're voting to delete
something or reduce something
that may be in a contract then aren't
you breaking the law not according to
those no but that's what i mean it's my
thing is that to me this is common sense
if i'm reducing something i was a
selectmen also on the school board and
also on the budget committee for 22
years not at the same time but i know
how how these things are done and
they've done
because i remember when i was on the
school board i did not approve the
budget because the default was always
wrong
and and i but
well that's what the law says but yeah
you're manipulating the law that was not
the intent of the law the intent was the
default should always be lower or why
would you have that in law okay thank
you
any other questions
yes purpose
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
does this then assume that the default
budget
would would ebb and flow as the
operating budget then ebbs and flows by
any changes made by the budget committee
official budget committee or the
town meeting
no the problem is the default
unless there's one section that nobody
passes that the default budget is has to
be done by the governing body period so
yeah if
that's another issue if if the budget
could still end up being
higher
if the
budget committee
reduces money or on the floor delivered
a session to reduce money but the point
is this would just
let's make it fairer in other words if
i'm if the governing body is reducing
something let's make it transparent that
the default has also got that same
reduction there is also possibilities
yes what you said could happen
but the point is let's have the school
board or governing body sell the budget
not just make it automatic
that people are going to vote yes
because it's lower
yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
you're talking about the towns right so
how would this impact the cities no okay
no just for towns that have
voted for the municipality law which is
what we used to be called everybody's
still calling an sb2 because that was
senate bill 2 in 1995.
okay thank you just clarifying
any other comments or questions
seeing none
thank you representative appreciate it
very much thank you
and that closes the hearing on hb 1070.
we have a few minutes
i'm sorry
oh you did all right i'm sorry
yeah
i don't i don't have uh
here we go
okay miss heck
please uh
come up and tell us what's on your mind
good morning chairman dolan and members
of committee my name is catherine heck
from the new hampshire municipal
association
and our position is that we have to
oppose the bill on the technicalities
that it proposes within the law
i understand that in 2018 house bill
1370 and senate bill 342 made some
significant clarifications to how a
default budget should be calculated so
that it was conservatively done and
many factors would be considered
we do have a handout that i will leave
for you that nhma has produced for our
members to explain what those changes
are so there are not um
mistakes in those default calculations
for the sb2 towns but when speaking um
regarding this bill as it reads and line
9 less any reduction to appropriation
the governing body made in the proposed
budget
the default budget is based on a
previous year's proposed
approved budget rather the proposed
approved amount not what the actual
expenditures were
so
in this case it kind of creates a circle
of redundancy in that if you're sitting
at your deliberative session and the
legislative body chooses to reduce an
amount or the governing body has made a
reduction that they're bringing forth
the default budget cannot accept that in
its calculation using the ms-737 for a
budget committee or the ms-636 because
the legislative body has not yet
approved that amount so for cutting
teachers a governing body or a budget
committee might say and of course i i
don't that's a terrible example but
he did bring up cuttings cutting
positions i should say if that's the
case the legislative body has not
approved those cuts so they could in
fact say we would like to maintain those
positions whether it's our highway
people or any other salaried position
so
i do understand the intent is to clarify
what the law is however default budgets
due to things like one-time expenditures
or warrant articles can in fact end up
higher than the prior years
in the next year's proposed budget
because maybe you did a large project
that you don't anticipate doing again
your default budget from last year would
in fact be higher because the voters
approved that one-time project so we do
have some concerns with this language as
the legislative body has not been
considered
how it would affect the intent of what
the sponsor is trying to do
so i can certainly take any questions
yes could you
for the benefit of edification of the
committee explain
the difference between the legislative
body and the governing body
of course so the legislative body are
the voters the registered voters who
come to the deliberative session in an
sb2 town to cast their votes and approve
what the governing body has proposed the
governing body and budgeting in this
case could be
the school board the select board or an
official budget committee of a school
district or a town so
and we would
also point out that again that ms 737 or
is what the default is supposed to be
based off of so any new
additions
certainly should not be in the default
budget because the voters have not
approved them
but i can understand the conundrum that
we discussed just in this room a few
days ago of the default budget ending up
somehow higher than the proposed budget
and i again i will leave the handout
that explains exactly how we interpret
the law and the recommendations we make
to our members to ensure that the
default budget is properly calculated
representative
thank you mr chair thank you miss
hex for taking my question you kind of
somewhat clarified
my question in my mind you know the
base budget
is the approved budget from the previous
year and that becomes the base budget
that you're working off of so it's not
the
um previous
operating budget because at the end of
the year what the budget was is not what
the operating budget could be slightly
different correct
okay my one more follow-up yes go ahead
uh thank you mr chair um my other
question is again
how many towns
will be affected if this becomes a law
i do not know off the top of my head how
many sb2 towns
that we have i don't know if my
colleague do you know do you know how
many nage
yes i'm over here sorry sir
um thank you for taking my question
would you agree
that
the intent of the law
would be if at deliberative session
the
voters
disapproved
the operating budget because
they felt it was too high
okay
and
then the fallback position
the
default budget
is higher
than the proposed budget when it comes
to voting
would you agree that that shouldn't
happen very often
and if it happens repeatedly
year after year after year
that there is a problem with the law
i think that's a complex question
because when we're looking at our
default budget we're also considering
anything else that the voters have
approved on the warrant including
warrant articles so
which is fully in the legislative body's
control to approve or not approve so if
they're approving large projects
one-time projects year-over-year say
paving a giant parking lot or doing over
a townhouse
if they're approving that and that is
their will of the people and the voter
to do that it would be very complicated
to say that
the default budget would not end up
higher what i think
the intent is
when the governing body has that occur
and they have a lower budget my hope is
that it's not to have any type of
deception it's because they are saying
we don't need to do that one time
project again and therefore the budget
is lower i'm i'm hoping that um
and knowing the communities that we work
with they're just doing the calculation
based on based on the law and what the
voters have put forth and approved in
the previous year sir so
i
i don't think that's the intent and i
think when the governing body is or the
budget committee is bringing forward an
operating budget or and a warrant that's
lower than the default it's because they
took great care in deciding
in this current year what the one-time
projects or additional needs of that
community are so i think it's a very
complicated question and if there's
individual communities
that are experiencing this
i think that they should look at what
they've been approving as a legislative
body actually
would you would you agree that
what's up
before sb2
everybody came to the town meeting
or the school board or the school
district meeting
and the budget there was no default
budget the budget was decided at that
meeting
then we came along with sb2
which gives everyone in town registered
voters
the ability to vote on the proposed
budget
the default budget was inserted in there
as a fallback position
if the proposed operating budget failed
okay
so
i contend
that the default budget if it is higher
than the proposed operating budget
that that's a problem
because
the
school board if they're able to do that
then they could care less about the
operating budget
because the default budget's going to be
higher anyway
so i think that the way
people are
manipulating the numbers
is a real problem and i think that this
bill
supports
what was the original intent of the law
would you agree with me on that
i have no opinion on that sir
respectfully okay
uh
miss heck
would would you agree that
that if a community
was putting
one-time
expenditures
into an operating budget that's probably
not the proper way to budget
there are
every community has its own culture and
climate so you can put one-time
expenditures into your operating budget
you can have separate warrant articles
certainly collective bargaining
agreements contract and multi-year
contract also factor into this default
so if you have a multi-year collective
bargaining agreement the first year it's
a warrant article then it rolls in again
into your budget um
so unfortunately that again would cause
the default to be higher but the
legislative body approved that say three
year five year contract whatever the
case may be so i agree that it's very
complicated the town meeting allows for
the deliberation of the
operating budget and all the warrants
until the town is satisfied so no one
leaves or they have to reconvene until
the town is satisfied sb2 doesn't have
that same ability they have the
deliberative session so of course the
default
was a mechanism to your points are
created because they don't have that
same ability to just debate
until they're done and they can come to
consensus
to answer a question previously ask sir
if i may 72 towns are sb2 towns as of
2020.
thank you how do you characterize
charter
communities
sb2 are not sp2
as far as cities are concerned no
when you look at those numbers you just
quoted does that include charter
communities as well that's the list from
the dra so
i don't have that in front of me
thank you
representative
i'm sorry
representative wrong
thank you mr chair and thank you miss
for taking my question
um
so i just want to understand something
in in an sb2 town
the voters come to the deliberative
session and when they get to the budget
on the warrant
let's say the default budget is higher
than the proposed operating budget
are the voters able at that session to
move that the opera the proposed
operating budget
be
cut to even lower what
the operating budget was the year before
do they have that chance to
essentially
um
do what representative baum
you know is suggesting at that
deliberative session so they could
i'm saying they could cut the budget
lower than it was the year before or
anything and then
on
is it is it true that then on election
day
whatever changes they made at the
deliberative session will then appear on
the warrant with the default budget
that is correct they have the same
opportunity at the deliberative session
that the town meeting allows they can
adjust any line or any warrant article
as they see fit as the legislative body
so they have that opportunity a
deliberative session okay
they just don't vote
and the deliberative session votes to
bring that budget forward for a final
vote to the large an official vote of
the larger community
in a usually in about a month okay
follow-up thank you
and then so
assume that the deliberative body
cuts the budget so it's even lower than
the
preceding budget i mean okay it's maybe
they cut it 20 percent
and that gets approved on election day
does that then become the basis for the
default budget for the following year
yes okay thank you representatives davis
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i shouldn't even be
asking a question because i don't live
in an sb town i live in a city
but if if the
supposition of this bill
is that it will
avoid people
uh quote-unquote manipulating the
numbers upward
isn't it also true that people could
manipulate the numbers downward
so they already have the ability to
to change the budget to representative
rungs point um at the deliberative
session but again the default is based
on an approved budget from a prior year
so the language in the bill is taking
that power away from the legislative
body's binding vote from the prior year
and that is the concern and how we can't
seem to reconcile that when i try to do
this in practice because i end up kind
of in a circular pattern with the
proposed language
in that
if if the deliberative session does make
that
or the governing body
proposes that change i can't undo a vote
of the previous legislative body so
there's kind of an unreconciliation
between the governing body or budget
committee as the case may be and the
legislative body and the language that
i'm currently reading
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so um
this is an abstract somewhat abstract
topic for those who are not familiar
with sb2 towns and how that works
my school district is an sb2 town but i
just want to clarify the the process
in my understanding so in lines a page
one lines fifteen through sixteen
it says that in calculating the default
budget amount the governing body shall
follow the statutory formula which may
result in a higher or lower amount than
the proposed operating operating budget
so going into the sb2 deliberative
session
the default budget is determined as is
the the operating budget both are known
so um to go back to your testimony
you stated that the governing body be it
the school board if there's no official
budget committee
whatever whatever or the budget
committee brings forth that operating
budget
they vote on it is that correct
they they vote on it before they bring
it to the deliberative session the
deliberative session is a vote of the is
for the legislative body so that's the
budget they are bringing forward for the
legislative body to deliberate and
decide if they would like to move it up
or down or change any line they could
zero out a warrant article
they just can't propose any new business
because it has to meet the stay-at-home
test that's why petition-worn articles
for example have to be submitted in
advance
so the governing body does not vote at
that meeting at that point we have
turned over the budget as a governing
body to the people and let them decide
um and then whatever the decision is
made at that meeting is what moves
forward for the the official vote
follow-up yes go ahead thank you thank
you mr chair
so that that yes that confirms my
understanding and perhaps i misspoke
the governing body whoever owns the
budget they they make a recommendation i
misspoke if i said vote they vote to
make a recommendation
so if i um also understand your
testimony
um you pointed out a technicality in the
way that this language in in the bill
was written
in that the if if the
at the deliberative session
if the uh default budget is amended
that poses a problem because the
governing body
then
has not provided a recommendation with
regard to that amended default budget so
my question is
could
this language be changed so that
before that
default budget goes on the warrant could
the governing body
take a vote to approve or
disapprove of that operating budget so
the default budget is not deliberated
that again is a calculation based on the
prior year's legislative body's approval
there is no ability to change the
default calculation because that
calculation has to be disclosed properly
noticed to the public it has to be
produced and it's based on
the documents that are provided to the
department of revenue administration so
again it is supposed to be calculated
based on the law so there is no
opportunity for the default to be
questioned because it's already been
approved in the prior year's budget i
hope that answers your question
representative power
representative mitchell
thank you mr chair and thank you ms heck
for taking my question and this maybe
should have addressed to the to the
sponsor
um is it i said on the select board of
my town is it possible that when my
proposed budget came in or the proposed
budget came in with an eight percent
increase that i could have just
rubber stamped that
to then create
the
basis for the default budget and then
sent that off to the
budget committee which is an official
budget committee in northampton to do
what they're going to do and now have a
default budget with an eight percent
increase in it
is that possible so you're talking about
the budget you're proposing versus a
budget that's already been developed and
accepted so yes this says
parent three says less any reductions to
an appropriation the governing body made
in the proposed operating budget so my
question is could i have received an
eight percent increase
to
a operating budget and said
all good
yes and that won't change your default
budget because any new budget
moves forward through the processing and
i think this is the circle
that i
continue to find myself in it
because we're talking about a proposed
budget eliminating reductions in a
budget that has not yet been approved in
a default budget that has already had
voter approval and they're kind of
completely two separate and distinct
budgets and points in time so
i i apologize if i'm not answering your
question properly
any other comments
yes uh representative guthrie uh this
may thank you for taking my question
thank you mr chairman
this may have already been answered but
is it my understanding that the default
budget
is only monitored if you will by dra
is that correct
um i would have to defer to dra for the
term monitoring um it's certainly up to
the community to
fill out the form and submit it to the
dra
and of course they have a internal
system but i cannot speak to that i
apologize uh follow up with you
maybe i didn't ask the question
properly isn't it a fact
that if the governing body
puts together a default budget
that is submitted to dra
that that very well could be the end of
the process
i i'm not sure i understand your
question but we do have a dra
representative here who may or may not
be able to answer that i i don't want to
misspeak on behalf of a state agency
just a clarification i'm sorry i'm
asking the same question
i'm trying to uh if you will
it's my understanding that in fact the
default budget
really
no but nobody outside of the governing
body
has any control over the default budget
in fact it goes forward
there is
there is no am i correct when i say
there really is no process
to
uh assure that the fall budget does not
go forward
uh under the control of the governing
body
so
i guess i'll go back to again
the control of the default budget
occurred in the previous
budget cycle with the legislative body
and
i agree that it's a complicated
calculation that towns have to go
through
but they are required to notice
a detailed default budget right
alongside their their proposed budget so
they have to have a completely separate
line by line default calculation so
again that could be questioned at any
time through the budget process which is
an open and public and transparent
process
so usually starting in november and
december that is being looked at very
carefully
by miss
to their side i just want to be sure to
to clarify that it is
it is not up to the governing body the
default budget it is up to them and
their staff to make sure the calculation
is correct but again it was already
approved by the legislative body and
it's a fully transparent
process and you can you have to present
the default budget line by line not just
a number to the legislative body when
you go to vote so they can see
apples to apples what has changed or
what has not changed sir
guthrie let me suggest that we bring dra
up and have them
thank you
questions i think i think they'll give
you some more details
thank you mr jim i'm sorry dad thank you
very much for the input
you're welcome
so mr newer if you would uh come up and
and join miss hector
at the front table in the meantime
representative power you had a follow-up
thank you mr chair um
thank you for taking my second question
so this is for the new hampshire
municipal
association
i unfortunately missed with the prime
sponsor
his comment with regard to line 23
and the strikeout of rsa 197 colon six
is that with regard is that a
an era scribner's error that they're
they're fixing now is that
reference petition warren articles could
you comment on the
validity of that
change there it appears that that is a
an rsa that deals with school districts
so it should be considered whether you
would like that rsa stricken from this
law as it pertains to school districts
but i i can't speak to that further i
represent the municipalities i'm sorry
so we have a representative from dra
here could you introduce yourself and uh
could you tackle the question from
representative guthrie certainly uh for
the record my name is bruce kenour i
serve as the supervisor of the municipal
bureau at the department of revenue
administration
and if i may mr chairman yeah
thank you for
coming forward i'm trying to
if you will i'm trying to
establish the fact that the
default budget
is under the control of the governing
body
and then in fact they can put before
the legislative party
there
default budget
and that although it goes
it eventually goes to the dra
that that kind of oversight by the dra
is not
the governing
uh
body that will determine what the
default budget is i don't know if that's
clear enough i'm just trying to
clarify that that there is not
very much control
over the dra over the default budget by
anybody other than the governing body if
the border selectmen or the school board
says that this is the default budget and
it gets into
if you will a skunk contest because i
can't use the
the p wood
that
when it gets push and shove it's the
governing body that says i want to
include this in my default budget
representative guthrie
you are correct there's nothing in
statute that gives the department of
revenue authority to review or approve a
default budget we see the information go
by because with the advent of the tax
portal back in 2015
as a municipality constructs
its budget it's doing so in that
computer portal
and it
knows that it's an sb2 governed
municipality or school district so
before it lets it finish the work
of inputting all the data and producing
the actual budget form that needs to be
signed and posted it alerts the
municipality to school district and says
you can't finish because you're sb2
you need to complete a default budget
that's the extent of our involvement we
have no jurisdiction to look at it
i will say that
one to clarify one point now catherine
had mentioned about the sanctity of the
default budget it's created and there it
is
there's one wrinkle in the law again we
we only know this at dra because we're
peppered by questions and have to say
the same thing we do not
evaluate or approve them
is that
at a deliberative session
there can be discussion about the
default budget there can be
argumentation
but there's no power of the legislative
body to amend however
before the default budget number goes on
the official ballot
this little section in 4013 says that um
this amount that would be the default
budget amount shall not be amended by
the legislative body that catherine's
point however this amount may be
adjusted by the governing body
and then if it's the school board or the
board of selectmen unless those entities
have voted to give such authority to to
a budget committee
that's rare
so
the governing body
acting on relevant new information at
any time before the ballots are printed
providing the governing body and
completes an amended budget form so at
deliberative if there is great
discussion and argumentation about the
default budget amount
the governing body listening to that
has the authority before they send it to
the printer for the ballot
they can
create a different default budget amount
they'll go through the portal again
create it
so there is one slight moment
where
a default budget amount could change the
other thing that we have witnessed we
have no part in it we're not a party to
any of the
litigation
but in 2016 and then again in 2017 there
were superior court decisions
about the validity of the construction
of a default budget
one was timely enough that it actually
was ordered by the court that the entity
would go back and do it again
and one wasn't timely enough but the
court did weigh in
on it so there's that um
i won't say ability to amend but perhaps
the incentive
to um uh not have to amend it by court
order so those that sits there
but certainly i want to confirm your
your conclusion
is that
dra is not involved in the approval or
the review of these
and we always would do you know if we
get a question from an entity
we defer them back to their own legal
counsel to determine whether or not
they're constructing it according to the
law to the best of their ability
thank you very much i think they
clarified what i was looking for and i
thank you mr chairman sure
are there any other questions
yes representative loseless
thank you for taking my question um
if we're in a period
where
the demand for services
is going
down but the
let's say we have a
declining enrollment in a school system
but the school board is not inclined
to reduce their operating budget
and it comes to the deliberative session
and there's a great hubbub
about the fact that even though we have
declining enrollment
the budget is still
abnormally high
and this
you say that the school board
could if they
felt so inclined
to go back and look at the default
budget
and reduce
if
is that what your testimony was
yes representative
it's merely
a section of the existing law
that is
easily easily enough
not seen
because it's so rare that anything can
touch that default
budget number but there is that small
window in the law where yes the
governing body which created it to begin
with
has an opportunity after
if they're persuaded
and then that's a dra has no position on
whether they should shouldn't or
anything else but it's there follow-up
mr chairman
i submit to you
that the reason that is so rare
is that the school boards in this case
and i'm merely using that as an example
are never inclined to reduce their
budget
that
they
they if the operating budget is
disapproved oh well
it's when if we get it approved and when
if we don't
because the default budget is higher
so i submit to you that
in in those sets of circumstances
if the school board is so inclined that
the budget would never go down
well i have in the department we have no
position on the inclinations of the
governing bodies of any entity or
entities
um
so i'm not sure i can
respond let me say you don't have to
answer that because i don't think
representative lasallis really asked you
a question i think he's
what you're hearing is some frustration
coming from him
with the government that he's observing
i think the correct word is pontificate
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
like i said this is an abstract
subject
and i might be oversimplifying this
but the default budget is defined in
statute
and on line four it says
i understand that it says in the
operating budget authorized for the
previous year
and then the subsequent lines go on to
further
um explain or define how that
calculation shall be made
and so currently in statute there's two
provisions
in which that default budget that was
authorized i didn't mean default budget
that the previous year's budget
that had been authorized previously can
be reduced or increased
by um
as defined in in sections one and two so
my question is
can not the legislature
um redefine and and further add
provisions by which
the default budget is calculated
it would be your prerogative to do so as
a policy position representative
follow-up
therefore
it is not lines nine through ten um
you know valid
because it's
it's redefining how the default budget
shall be calculated
um
i would note representative that i think
the historical
record indicates those court cases
did precisely that
uh
past sessions have amended this section
of law
one of which was if i'm not mistaken it
was the 2016 case was about contracts
and the next session
will add language about uh inclusion or
or not of contracts so
to a second if you will catherine's view
of course we would
defer to the legislature about what the
law would be or could be
good
any other questions
yes representative gallagher
hi um
so
for the um
the person from drak i just get your
name again for note-taking purposes and
how it's spelled certainly first name is
bruce last name is k-n-e-u-e-r
okay thanks you're welcome
okay and
next we have uh representative
sorry we have mr natchez from uh mr
gray's i'm sorry from nhma to make some
commentary
okay
representative dolan yes may i just let
the committee know that um in our budget
faq from nhma it does cite some of the
legal court cases that have come to pass
for for your reference and i'll leave
that for your review thank you yeah i do
remember the uh
the output of the the contracts
controversy uh
that was very uh
very well publicized so
yes
mr chairman at the risk of being a
glutton for work punishment
i would note about three four years ago
and i do not remember who someone in the
legislature asked
in effect my desk to look at what
happened the prior year in sb2
situations in other words was the
default budget higher or lower than the
recommended operating budget
and what was the outcome
um
i i'm not asking to do it again but if
there is a need somehow to determine
whether or not
that disparity and calculate or those
values leads to any kind of um obvious
voting pattern
uh
it could we could put that together
thank you very much
one last follow-up
well um if you already did it once
instead of doing it again could you just
send us the
previous one
i'm sure i could find
my
spreadsheet as it were i can tell you
what i concluded i looked at it and i'm
not a statistician but there was nothing
that jumped off the page that said
anything
was dramatically happening
whichever way the the two numbers
rested
but it wasn't meant to be a truly
scientific quantitative analysis but it
was just a look
so if i can
would i send that
yes please send it to me and uh i'll
copy the
committee
all right thank you very much that
concludes our hearing on house bill
1070.
and we had by the way
we had 11 people registered they were
for the bill and 28 opposed it
mr chair uh on the uh on online
testimony submissions i have a couple of
people that have registered twice
but this doesn't tell me who they're
representing whether it's a town and or
themselves
so i think you're getting a different
printout
repeated voted one actually
voted supported enough
so okay so it's just really to give us
an indication of
what the general thing is so i'll just
give you the
real number not with any manipulation of
subtracting the extra three opinions
i don't think so
okay we had we had an additional
individual who wanted to address the
committee um
chris
norwood
but i i've closed the uh
the hearing
oh it's the next bill okay
okay
yes i see that thank you
okay so we'll open the
the floor to house bill
and
i'll ask if there's
somebody in the audience that would like
to introduce the bill
no
any
you have a volunteer would like to
introduce it
okay representative van's going to
introduce the bill
well
we're looking for chris norwood to
introduce the bill
no
i'm sorry
so representative van you still want to
introduce the bill
okay
representative yokola
go ahead and introduce the bill please
thank you uh
chair and members of the committee
sorry i uh
look for the confusion i have a exec
session going in the other in my
committee and so i'm trying to
juggle both um
so
we got we are on um hb
uh 1087.
relative to zoning uh single family
housing lots and this is um a little bit
of
a
similar topic of a bill that
i believe the this committee may have
retained or killed last year
regarding the
lot size
of um
lot size requirements for
lots that are part of
a combined res
[Music]
water sewer treatment
and
so then
so there was some discussion about the
language and how
it would
um
be
affecting uh towns and so this new
language under online eight and nine
says that uh lots
uh
the lot or lot does not exceed the um
existing municipal or county uh
community water and sewer infrastructure
so that's
making sure that um
the the infrastructure is
has the capacity to have the additional
lots on it and um
and also
uh
the there is a change from the quarter
acre requirement to the one uh 10 000
square foot
acre requirement
as the maximum and that was um discussed
with a number of the representatives and
uh
over the summer to try and come with
come up with language that would be able
to be supported
there is uh
online 10 through 12. it's
just saying that this is um
not to
limit kind of the the requirements of of
group
or um
what is that called um
uh like high density housing
requirements
and so hopefully that this this bill as
drafted the language is more amenable to
the committee it's really the same
kind of topic it's just uh
trying to clean up the
you willing to take language questions
from the committee absolutely
anyone have questions for representative
ocala
yes
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
absolutely um i
do have a little bit of concern with the
new
uh number two friends number two
because
it's sort of a chicken and egg
thing
would you say that
if a
if a town is already at maximum
water and sewer capacity then no
new buildings can be built that's no
so
thank you for the question so this is
regarding lots
size and so it would be
um so this is in relation to creating a
new lot this is what when this would
come into play so if there are um you
know the there are
f
10 lots on this community's sewer and
water and this
the com the community sewer and water
can only
hold or support
10 buildings then adding an additional
one would be one that exceeds the
current
ability so that lot would not fall under
this requirement and they could still
require whatever acreages that they
that their normal requirements would be
thank you yes thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you representative
appreciate you being here thank you
next up we have
mr chris norwood
thank you mr chair
members of the committee my name is
chris norwood welcome mr nolan thank you
uh i'm here today representing the new
hampshire association of realtors
and uh just calling up some bullet point
notes that i have on my phone
um
the new hampshire association of
realtors is supportive of this bill um
and i think that the uh
the main crux behind the bill or the
hopeful results of the bill will lead to
more housing and i won't uh bore
everyone with housing statistics i think
we all know the challenges that we face
today in our state with housing and its
impact on our economy
um we do believe that if there is a
municipality that has a public water and
public sewer system
that uh it would be behoove the
communities to
allow for a denser population in those
in those environments down to the 10 000
square foot lot size as uh
as noticed in the bill
um so just a couple quick things that
kind of two takeaways that i want to
impart upon the committee the first
thing is historically how did we get to
our current lot size in the various
municipalities and so
most municipalities will have a default
lot size of around two acres and i think
that most folks are familiar with that
concept
there are some municipalities that have
higher lot sizes in some zones some that
say the lot size has to be all high and
dry you can't have wetlands as part of
your two to four or five acres we even
know of one municipality that has a 10
acre zone
so but how do we get to the two acre
size well the two acre size is really a
it's a geometry problem with your well
radius and your septic system and making
sure that typically on your average two
acre lot you have enough room for a well
a radius around that well and then a
place outside that radius to put a
septic system and if that system fails
to have another septic uh
area for a septic system
um so with all that said if you were on
municipal water and municipal sewer the
two acre lot size just doesn't meet the
historic reasons of why
the two acre lot size was kind of
became the foundation of our state so
many years ago
and so that's just one consideration i
would like to leave you with
the other item that i would like to
leave you with is that there there are
municipalities that do
have denser lots in their
more densely populated downtown
environments where municipal water and
sewer
is located i think that the challenge
that we have is that
there is research uh done by the josiah
bartlett center and i'd urge everyone to
go to their website that would suggest
that um unfortunately we do have
communities that are not
doing their fair share as it relates to
putting on more housing stock in our in
our state and what we see bless you what
we see is that when
community a starts to
ratchet up their regulations in their
built environment the neighboring
communities follow suit because there's
a fear that if neighboring community a
isn't doing their fair share well
community b needs to pull up the
drawbridge as well
and we feel that a level set playing
field for those communities that do have
water and sewer uh we feel that this
bill is as a fair uh way to tackle the
issue and recognizing that not all
communities have a municipal water and
municipal sewer and with that mr
chairman i'll be happy to take any
questions
questions from the committee
yes representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
wouldn't there with something that this
goes through
i can tell you that in the city of nash
we'd lose about six
zoning
locations from that but putting that
aside don't you fear
that some communities that do not have
municipal and water
would um be less likely to they're going
to try to stick with the sewer they're
going to try to stick with well water
and so on so that they don't
they won't fall into this if they try to
tie into a municipal water supply
that's a concern that i personally have
so thank you representative for the
question if i understand it correctly
your concern is that would
municipalities without private without
municipal water and sewer um
keep that status
um
yes and no because my practice is uh
commercial real estate and in one of the
things that i think most municipalities
like
is a as a commercial tax base
and many uses that i work with on a
day-to-day basis
need municipal water and sewer and if
they don't have municipal water and
sewer it's economically impractical uh
daycare uses most food service uses
these are uses that you can do on um on
a private system but if you have
domestics if you have it municipal
service of water and sewer
it becomes immensely easier so
i i hear clearly the concern
uh but i think then it would go to the
other property classifications
namely commercial uses
where
municipal water and sewer really are
needed for economic growth and for that
diversification of one's tax base
thank you thank you
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
is it true that um single family housing
lots
are restricted to residential areas or
does that vary from municipality to
municipality
thank you for the question
representative um
yes various municipalities have um
various zones
that would allow for either single
family or
commercial development or agricultural
as it were
representative manchapudi
i yield to representative vance she's
had her hand up before me
thank you chairman and thank you
representative man djibouti
uh am i correct
having you deal with real estate
in terms of the dollars and cents am i
correct in understanding that the price
the raw price of the land
for a new single family house is about
20 percent of the sale price of the
house
thank you representative for the
question uh
so i i grew up at the kitchen table with
both my parents in real estate and that
was the old rule of thumb they always
taught me um
it's all over the map these days and so
i i think most builders still use 20 to
25 as a rule of thumb
um but obviously the last 20 years and
even the last five has seen
inflationary numbers right follow-up uh
you're a co-sponsor right no you're not
okay not i i was just volunteering
because i care
uh so
my follow-up question is so if we take
the 20-25 even higher as being um the
cost of the of the raw land relative to
the sale price is it not true that the
larger the lot the larger the house you
have to build in order to not lose your
shirt
yes thank you representative for the
question and i think that that's what
we've seen in today's market is that
there is uh an arms race for larger and
larger homes
uh and the median home price today is in
excess of four hundred thousand dollars
and um
i don't even know what a starter home is
considered these days
follow follow one more
i'll be done after this uh
so
if we agree that the sale price of the
home is directly tied to the price of
the lot
how likely is it that a builder is going
to buy a two acre lot and put a house
that
if we figure 200 a square foot
is going to cost 150 000 how likely is
that to happen
that the and sale price will be 150
thousand dollars well it'll be the 150
plus whatever you paid for the land and
absolutely and there needs to be uh
finance charges uh the the developer is
entitled to a profit for the risk of all
their capital outlay and so forth so
and the broker fee there's got to be a
broker fee in there representative uh
but although i use tongue-in-cheek no i
think that the the result of your
question yes the uh the land value is
directly tied to the value of housing
and there's a lot of variables today
with uh increased lumber prices
increased labor prices but clearly
clearly the values of the land
is derived from the lack of supply that
we have out there
thank you
yes representative manchin foodie
thank you mr chair
thank you for
taking my question sorry i had a brain
brain cap
cramp brain cramp sorry
my question is
um
lot size dictates the size of the house
and it also dictates the
the covenant with each development the
developer brings that
also dictates some of the
structure and
setting and whatever the cost of the
house depends on the
how would this affect
and
i'll add one more thing to that with the
covet situation where
you know home office would not consider
commercial single family
we had three people working from home
last week
home office is all virtual they don't
have a space to go
and so would that change
uh with this
single family and not for commercial or
office purposes
thank you representative for the
question uh so i live in an urban
environment where my house lot
if i recall is like point
two acres right so that's about uh
yeah it's a little bit smaller right and
and there's a generous size house on
that i will say we do not have the home
office i work from the bed uh when i'm
working from home um but i do think that
you can you can afford to put a decently
sized square foot home provided that
there are not other regulations such as
uh onerous side and front yard setbacks
um and and i think that if uh in a bill
such as this were enacted i don't think
that you need uh two acres to have a
a size house that is presently in demand
in the market i think uh we've often
referred to the missing middle in our
housing supply and i think that this
bill would help
supply that missing middle and i would
also say it would help put those housing
units
near the existing infrastructure of the
municipality typically water and sewer
is located near your
services that the community provides and
i think that that's where we would like
to see some additional development
rather than
more development in otherwise virgin
green space representative stavis
i think you just answered the question i
was going to ask but i'll give it a try
anyway i wanted to ask you about the
environmental impact
of large lot zoning
um
do you think that
allowing
preventing
cities and towns from limiting
from limiting lot size to larger lots
would have a positive impact on the
environment by taking up less green
space
impacting fewer wetlands
and keeping our state the beautiful
state that we all love
thank you representative for the
question i i don't think it's a matter
of of um
having
two
two types of housing in contrast to one
another i think that both can exist at
the same time within this bill this bill
is simply saying that in our more
densely
uh municipal water municipal sewer built
environment that we afford more density
in those areas
towns can still have
their zoning elsewhere outside of the
water and sewer district
that may afford the two acre zoning that
i otherwise would have mentioned there
is a need for it to have the well radius
and so forth
but i would say what i previously stated
is yes it makes a lot more sense i think
for um
those municipal services ambulatory uh
fire police the denser populations to be
located in that area with the water and
sewer i think makes sense from a uh
from a policy
development perspective
thank you thank you um
no more questions uh
i'm going to uh oh we have one more
question
yeah just my standard could you please
repeat your name just for note-taking
purposes
certainly uh chris norwood
c-h-r-i-s-n-o-r-w-o-o-d
all right thanks representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so thus far the
conversation has been centered around
lots that are owned by a developer
is it true that if an individual
purchase
purchases a lot and they own the lot
then they can
build whatever size
home they want on that lot
yes so this doesn't have to be a
developer taking a
single
one acre lot and splitting it up into
four
this could be
a homeowner who owns a piece of land or
the homeowner themselves owns an acre
and they wish to sell off
a quarter acre so that they can retire
in place
by building a house on a quarter acre
that they can retire next to where they
raise their children um and there's a
lot of discussion taking place within
the real estate community about retiring
in place and how difficult it is in our
state so i hope that answers the
question representative
thank you very much i appreciate your
testimony thank you mr chair and
our last speaker is
from nhma
mr graves
thank you mr chair nate graves from the
new hampshire municipal association
we do oppose this bill um we have a
policy at the uh
adopted policy for um this biennium that
we support long-standing authority of
municipalities to regulate land use
matters with minimal interference from
the state
and we oppose statewide land use
mandates
as far as practical considerations go
the one that i could identify was the
one that representative clee
spoke about earlier which is
it may be the case that there is less
incentive for municipalities to build
out water and sewer infrastructure and
i'm happy to take questions
questions
for nhma
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
and that concludes the hearing for
house bill 1087.
thank you and the the numbers for this
particular bill were 28
in support
seven opposed and three were neutral
i'd like to make a note on this one that
one person signed in both opposed and in
support okay thank you and there are pdf
uh documents testimony to read
that we we find that uh
those these uh
participation uh notes are not very
scientific and sometimes have duplicates
on them
there was a handout
for the last bill from
ms heck
i didn't get that does anybody know if
there's
gonna have to make copies uh oh okay
thank you
okay uh next we're going to uh
here house bill 1098
and i have an amendment that goes with
this bill which we we would
discuss at the
at the executive session
but you're welcome to
speak about it
but we're not going to vote on it today
thank you uh
chair
and members of committee uh
for the record my name is uh
representative joshua keller from
fremont danville and brentwood
i'm here to
very shortly uh
introduce
my bill limiting the number of parking
space required per occupied dwelling the
amendment um
just makes sure that it is not just one
uh space per
uh
lot
occupied lot but occupied dwelling so if
there's
15 houses they can't just have one
parking space kind of a thing
er as a maximum
um and so my uh
so the amendment language is just that
the local legislative body shall not
adopt ordinances requiring more than one
um
no no that's the original bill sorry
the amen uh the amendment um
specifies off-street parking
um
also i'm not sure that this is
her occupied dwelling yeah
i think this is
this is correct um
so my my
in kind of uh
you may be noticing a pattern with my
bills in that they are trying to
reduce the cost of housing i
as um
the previous and one of the previous
speakers mentioned i live on a very
small
lot um
just like they do and
my house was affordable because of that
um
and
it would be
for me to sell and and try and find
another comparable lot i don't actually
think that it would be possible um
because they're not being built because
it's not allowed anymore and so i'm just
trying to um say
um
that kind of uh my philosophy is like
there is there is a limit on what the
there's kind of a balance of
um people's property rights to be able
to
and and um
the state interest in saying hey we're
going to you know do we're going to
require 10 parking spaces we're going to
require 100 lot or 100 acres
you know these are burdens on those
those homeowners and
there needs to be a compelling state
interest before we start um limiting
people's
um ability to use their
their lot their
houses their lots their
property in the way that they seek to
and
i'm suggesting here that
um you know there is an opportunity for
over regulation in this this space that
will once again increase the cost of
housing in this state which we all know
is a big issue and so
um
my hopes is that you would be able to
support um either
this or even um you know amending it to
two lots if that's what the committee
says but this that there should be some
guidelines that it's not the wild wild
west that you can just regulate you can
the legislative body can just make up
whatever rules that they want and place
it on those um homeowners
in that in their area and so that's
i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
it's two-part question sure one i see
you're
where you're going with all your bills
right in terms of
trying to increase the density increase
the affordable housing
in our communities
and
by reducing the parking
is the intention
to provide more walkable livable
communities which is not car dependent
community that way
it makes
building communities not building just
homes
thank you for the question i think that
yes if you have a current setup which is
forcing large parking lots um then
you're going to be able to put that out
in
you know far away from the normal
services and it's going to be harder for
people to to work and play in those
areas and if and there are certain
people that you know want start starter
um
homes and and are
you know
let's say
in in an environment that maybe they
don't have a lot of people that are
going to be coming to their business or
i wanted to be able to um
you know there there's a development in
my town right now that has an apartment
complex and they're going way above the
number of parking spaces that is
required by our town and that should be
completely allowed but in this
maybe they're targeting a different
audience right with the with the and and
maybe it's
someone that you know they have a bus
line or something right in front of the
place and so most of the people that
they're targeting are people that are
not home or not car owners or or are
trying to do a more green or a biking
lifestyle or something like that and i
think that those people should be able
to um target those people if they uh you
know service that community and not um
artificially inflate the size of the lot
the size of the uh development and the
in in
and the cost of the development so that
those people that want that lifestyle
wouldn't be able to benefit from the
cost rece savings of having smaller
parking lots and you know the plow
requirements that come with that and
stuff like that so and and the
maintenance and and repaving and stuff i
think that that's
all something that you know as someone
someone they
could consider biking to work
might not want to have to pay for all of
that and and maybe they should be able
to uh benefit from that
in that situation but it wouldn't fit
every development right it would just
keep that that option open for those
people
so thank you
representative matt jury
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative taking my question you
stated a little while ago that needs to
be a compelling statewide interest to do
this i'm curious why
in my town which has two acre zoning and
has
um has adopted ordinances for parking
requirements based on setbacks and our
stated values for
wetlands
preservation of the environment
why there should be a compelling
statewide interest that overrides
my local interest on how to govern my
govern my own town
thank you for the question i think you
miss um quoted me i didn't say statewide
i said it's compelling state interest so
it would be you know the
if if it was let's say a wetland issue
then
um
they're i
not sure how how increased parking helps
helps the wetland but um
um
the
the uh i do think that
there needs to be some balance between
um
if the if the
town says you know
we need a
one mile buffer between
the wetlands and everything then should
that be allowed i don't i don't think
that's appropriate and so that's i think
that there's needs to be some boundaries
and you know
this is what
um you know when we say yes you can have
local control but it needs to be within
some
some reasonableness is kind of more my
my state
my um position and not that you can put
a one mile mile buffer around wetlands
kind of a thing so thank you
yes representative gallagher
um
hi yeah thanks for
introducing this bill and
so i actually have my own legislation
um regard that
addresses
um parking minimum requirements um
except
um
mine's more related to
um religious institution affiliated
projects um
that's hb1219
so i'm wondering um
do you
see this as
working together with that legislation
or is there any work we need to do to
harmonize
your bill with mine at all
thank you for the question i think that
um
if i remember correctly that that
legislation is kind of allowing
um
kind of multi-use of the spot so if it
if it if you have um someone that's only
using the parking space on sundays and
only someone that's using the parking
space during the week why they should be
able to count
those equally um
i think that this bill would not
conflict with that in any way and
any movement on that um
sounds sounds reasonable to me and
i don't think that
i'm happy to work with the with the
sponsor or the committee in in
making it if they see a conflict but i
don't i don't see a conflict at this
time thank you
thank you mr chair um i i do have kind
of a couple of questions but um
one of my concerns about something such
as this nature is that it does take away
that that local control and i'll give an
example and then ask you my question um
for instance nashua has a 1.5 parking
space per unit
um so in other words if there's five
apartments within one building
it's easier to say four apartments one
building they have to have six parking
spaces
oftentimes we find that's not adequate
because most
most um dwellers seem to have two cars
especially if they're a married couple
in the case of in the case of nashua
they gave a special exemption for um
a place that wanted to build um with no
parking absolutely no parking no on
street parking no any kind of parking
they came they got their special
exemption because it was right in the
heart of downtown and they felt that
they were building to that type of
community that you were talking about
that would walk and so on don't you
think it it's better to allow the
communities to do this than to handicap
them
where someone's going to be putting in
home and there really isn't adequate
parking but where our hands are tied
because you only have to have one
parking space
that's my concern so wouldn't you say
that you really could be handicapping
a current municipality
thank you for the question uh as a zba
member i'm well aware of the um
the
the requirements for uh
zoning
exceptions and
um it has to be uh
special to the lot some
certain characteristics that the lot has
that the things around it do not have
and in the example that i gave
for example was uh something along a bus
route or something like that there's um
the lot
uh
the surrounding lots obviously also are
really close to a bus route in that
example and maybe there is enough room
and so there's nothing
specifically
about that lot that makes not putting
you know 15 car lots or car spaces on
that lot it's just that they would
rather it be green
and they and that's the type of person
that they're trying to target and so
they wouldn't qualify for a special
exception and that expense because they
they have the lot size they have there's
nothing special about that lot that
grants them an exception to the rule and
so
i think that
legislation like this helps to
focus the community on
what is really the goal and the
importance of the
um
the regulation and say
are we trying to
make sure that there is um
and and as i also said that they're you
know
the developer kind of knows the kind of
their target audience and they're not
going to be able to sell to someone that
needs two cars if there's no parking
spaces right because that there will
be conflict and and people will
um
not
not be satisfied with with that
opportunity and so
the i don't believe that we're going to
be building
um
because of this bill in such a way that
it's not going to to be able to be sold
to the target audience and and that
those people will be satisfied with that
um i i'm saying that there is um
those people should have the option to
be able to do that and that um
i
am not sure that if there is you know
a one-bedroom house or one or a studio
apartment that that
can really only
um
is targeted to single occupants that
they need to have
two to parking spaces for that and so
it's um kind of just uh
uh opening it up for those situations to
be
um allowed and not hindered by
um
people being over aggressive in their
regulations
thank you um
well i guess my follow-up will be you're
talking about new development and i can
understand that the the the developer
should be planning
for his his or her target audience and
and i understand that but let's take um
a very large home
that's going to be converted into
multiple apartments or adus and so on
now you're putting the same restriction
on the municipality that they cannot
require more than
one space for occupy dwelling and i'm
going to take say that the the it being
separated into four
homes
means that they have to have four
parking spaces per year thing right so
so i i understand that i'm not saying
that the house itself only has one i'm
saying that the individual dwellings so
i do have that
but what if
there is there they they are two bedroom
apartments
that are going to be converted and trust
me i can tell you
we had we i have one in my
and in my ward in my district that has a
a home that they convert into five
and one of them has five bedrooms
and bae is renting it out with buy
parking spaces
and i'm getting those calls that they're
getting tickets because there's not
adequate parking um and saying to the
city why aren't you giving me enough
parking so just putting that aside
um aren't we
beyond the new development
this this does only does not just act
for new development it also acts for
existing homes that could be converted
is that correct
so this would be um
would be enforced when they're
um getting their essentially occupation
permit right and so if you got an if you
changed your setup of your lot to get
different occupation permits for each
um uh room of the
house then
um i'm not exactly sure and the example
that you gave if you already have like a
1.5 requirement in your town and you
they added
five
they converted a house then they would
need like 10 15 parking spots or or
eight maybe to be between eight and ten
parking spots and you're saying that
they
the people
instead of parking in those parking
spots or maybe they park in those
parking spots and then park on the
street but the street parking is not
allowed let's say in winter and they're
getting ticketed and then the people in
the the
on the um
that that were
in the are in the house renting are
complaining that they don't have enough
parking spots so that they are getting
ticketed and that's unfair
i'm i'm confused as because if they
accepted that that there was only going
to be one parking spot then that's kind
of
up to them to ch to accept that mr
chairman clarify yes
i'm sorry for my my confusing the way i
stated it um the
the city approved
for we'll say the four units six parking
spaces sure it's up to the landlord to
to deal those out accordingly right four
apartments
one of those apartments actually has
five bedrooms right
the landlord didn't say to those people
you only have x number of parking spaces
they move in it's not in the it's not in
the lease how many parking spaces they
see those that parking lot that's got at
least six i think in this particular
case i had seven parking spaces
they did not think oh they just figured
they're gonna have to buy for it in the
city of nashua we have a no parking
between midnight
and 4 a.m
because of safety of our high dense road
of our small roads and in high density
so
that's what i'm saying is for these
newer i agree with you for new
development it makes a lot of sense
but i i fear that we're having
unintended consequences of homes that
could be converted
that was my question to you okay thank
you thank you for the question i would
say um with the if the person moved in
that you know that could com entirely be
done you know the five bedrooms could be
filled up with you know two two adults
and five
three-year-olds that don't have any cars
and
and it's just
it could be all serviced by one van and
so the the
the
so maybe that situation would be
completely adequate for a different
family but it just doesn't work for that
family and that family um you know has
five teenagers and all that they all
have their own car and
it it really just doesn't work for them
and that isn't the town's fault or it
isn't the homeowner's fault it's kind of
when you're doing your due diligence
about fi you know living on a on a
property of
is this property going to suit my needs
and i would say that that is
not i i don't believe that it's the
town's fault i don't think that it's the
the
regulations fault i think that it's just
poor planning by the people that rent it
and that's
thank you chairman and thank you
representative yokola uh are you aware
of the work of the parking reform
network
oh but it sounds interesting
so
the parking reform network is an
organization that's been looking at
questions of over parking requirements
excessive parking requirements in the
united states
and
one of the things that they have
done is produce a map that shows places
that have changed their parking
requirements including the city of
buffalo new york a place where it snows
pretty often i think
and
the city of buffalo is the most famous
example of a place that has completely
eliminated its parking requirements
which is not the same as completely
eliminating the parking yeah um and i
guess my question is
why do you think that it works in
buffalo and might not work anywhere else
thank you for the question um i think
that um
if there's a demand for parking that the
developer will develop the parking for
it you know and in some towns or in some
areas there is not enough parking and so
you find parking structures that are
paid and some places even pay up
a lot
for parking um
definitely in seattle and and stuff like
that and so
i think that parking is is you know
driven by the market and not and um
for a demand in the market i'm not sure
exactly the the
the benefit of the
the government coming in and saying okay
nope nope you're
you need
additional parking
i think that it will be solved by the
people that are demanding the parking
that either it will be parking
structures or
um
or more bus lines and stuff like that or
yeah so i i'm not sure that it's a
government problem
so i think that it's possible that it
could work in many other places thank
you for the question
next we
have oh i'm sorry representative
manjuputi
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking another
question thank you and you alluded to
your last comment was
you know demand for more parking
versus if the pr you know public
transportation or mass transportation is
available so the demand for
public i mean parking will go down
wouldn't that be and you you know the
new millennial generation that's what
they want they want the smaller spaces
no parking uh
white
walkable livable communities
thank you for the question i
um
being um
a
a first-time homeowner
not too long ago
price was a big factor in how whether or
not i was going to be
able to uh afford it and
um so size
and i did i you know definitely in in
new hampshire we are taxed bait uh in
large part um
by the size of our home and so
being able to reduce those to uh support
someone that is just starting out in the
workforce um
is is important and
whatever costs um
can be reduced so that someone could
that that houses that
um
could be sold for 100 or 150 thousand
dollars
um
i think those need to be considered
absolutely thank you for the question
okay uh thank you very much
representatives uh mr grace you're up
in hma
thank you mr chair nate grace from the
new hampshire municipal association
we oppose this bill um not not only do
we uh impose statewide zoning mandates
but i believe there's some practical
considerations in this particular case
i looked over the statistics provided by
the u.s bureau of transportation
statistics bureau
or division
over the past 20 years and
uh they stated that
uh per household you know it ranges
slightly but the number of vehicles
owned per household ranges from 1.8 to
2.0
um and that's over the last two decades
and so that really works out to be for
the average american owns
75 of a car
um
realistically
that's problematic because
while we maybe
well some of the testimony today is
focused on you know cases of starter
homes
kind of first time home buying
situations
as representative clee pointed out it's
certainly possible in communities for
which have parking requirements for
developers to decide they want to target
that demographic with their particular
building or building style
and therefore obtain either a special
exemption if that's available or a
variance to reduce the number of parking
spaces required
but if we look at the best use of that
property and what that might be used for
in the future
you know it may be the case that uh
the neighborhood now is good for
you know first-time owners but later on
as it matures maybe it's better for you
know people who are retiring or
something like that or maybe it becomes
you know a new company comes into town
uh they
just you know people want to work there
and naturally as people progress through
lives they make they have relationships
they you know have other people live
with them
so realistically i think we need to look
more at the household numbers and
you know if you have we don't have a
good public infrastructure uh for
transportation in this state or country
so realistically we do rely on cars
and that's
you know may or may not change in the
future but
we have to plan for now as well as the
future uh and it makes sense to to
require that the uh
the buildings that are built um the
dwelling units that are built actually
have enough parking for the people who
occupy them now as well as may occupy
them in the future
and that is
much more in line with the local
considerations um
rather than a statewide mandate
because
the developer can come in
uh you know the local planning board
will have some understanding based on
their their master plan based on other
information provided at the local level
for how that community has developed
over time how it predict how it may
develop in the future um and
provide sort of guidance for the best
use of that property which is
going to include a certain number of
parking spaces
in most cases and i'm happy to take
questions
yes representative
van thank you chairman
thank you mr grace uh is it not true
that this bill doesn't prevent a
developer or a builder or whomever from
providing as many parking spaces as they
think is necessary it only says that the
town or the city or the jurisdiction
can't require it
that is correct but i
i think an analogy here might be useful
so
in the late 80s and early 90s many
developers came in and as a cost savings
measure
they decided to
retain when they built out subdivisions
they built up them as private roads in
20 years on we're seeing that
many people buying into these
communities weren't quite aware of that
or
they you know they are aware that they
pay some sort of community fee for
plowing and everything else but 20 years
on you need to replace those roads and
so all of a sudden they're hit with this
huge cost and so i think it's really
important we look ahead 20 years and say
well we can't really predict what's
going to happen but
presumably people still get married
presumably they still you know have to
go to work and they may need to drive we
don't know
yes follow-up
thank you for the follow-up uh mr grays
are you aware that the cost of a parking
space in the price of the house is about
twenty thousand dollars per space does
that not affect the price of the of the
dwelling
i agree that every every portion of the
dwelling would affect the cost
any other questions thank you thank you
seeing none thank you mr graves thank
you
that concludes our testimony for house
bill 1098
we're going to now open
testimony for house bill 1122 which is
authorizing municipalities to collect
and resell construction and demolition
debris
mr chairman uh the prime is on his way
so um
he's in executive session
and he's he's coming
is that okay well we take a five-minute
recess
and reconvene at uh
two minutes to twelve
are two minutes to eleven
so representative stavis
representative stavis
she's not hearing me
my question is what if these people that
are living in these apartments are
living in sin
does that control
shoot them
come on
representative majori i can't believe
she said that
really
you don't know how well
at one point um during something she
suggested that those villains be hoist
upon their patards
quoting from shakespeare which caused
many of us to then have to go look up
hoist empotards
we have a
church in exeter that's being converted
to 11 dwelling units
so can those people live in
well they don't have room to park
anymore
ugh
there you go
that sounds like
uh they only gave us one and she's
making copies for us
so yeah
i thought they knew better by now i know
what's that
i have a feeling that there shouldn't be
much
disagreement on this next
yes
i'd love to be the first okay
thank you tim
yes tim tim bean
eagan i'm sorry
got it okay we'll get you first thank
you so much
a little bit
okay
maybe not that long so i think this next
one's going to go pretty fast
okay let's uh get back into order
the next bill we're going to hear is
house bill 1122
which is authorizing municipalities to
collect and resell construction and
demolition debris
and we have tim egan here to
to introduce the bill and begin the
discussion
welcome
thank you mr chair thank you committee
for hearing me on 11 22.
if i'm out of breath i'm running back
and forth to r and d where we're
executing bills up and down the hall
um
hospital 1122 relative to authorizing
municipalities to collect and resell
construction and demolition debris is a
bill that is important to protecting our
environment minimizing solid waste in
our local landfills helping landowners
reduce new construction and renovation
costs supporting local home builders and
helping keep down the operational costs
of our communities transfer stations so
you may ask yourself how does collecting
and reselling construction demoly
demolition debris benefit our society
and save new hampshire residents money
well it allows construction and
demolition debris
to be sold it helps homeowners find
cost-effective building materials as we
all know where housing boom and
materials are prices are rising and
reusable materials could be cost
effective to homeowners that are looking
to do construction
allowing conduct construction and
demolition debris also helps transfer
stations potentially raise new revenue
as they would have the option of
collecting and reselling this material
allowing collecting
construction demolition degree also
forges partnerships with community home
builders and local contractors having
them understand and respect uh the
amount of
uh
excuse me
the amount of demolition debris that can
potentially go into landfills and figure
out better ways to reuse it
putting less
construction demolition debris into our
solid waste stream will reduce town
transfer station tipping fees which
hopefully will then reduce property
taxes on towns
and less peaking fees and costs for
transfer stations
can also help reduce town operation
costs because they'll see revenue from
potentially reselling this material
and lastly putting less construction
demolition debris into our solid waste
stream lengthens the lifespans of our
existing landfills and reduces our needs
for new ones because we all no matter
where you live in the state no one wants
to see a new landfill built near them
and if we can do our best to reduce the
amount of waste going into them we
extend their lifespan
this is not a new idea the rest
repurposing of construction and
demolition debris is an action step that
was based on the direction of the
2019 findings report on the committee of
studying recycling streams and solid
waste management plan that the house
passed
and it is an optional program it allows
for local governance where transfer
stations and oversight from their board
or town suck board or town
if they decide
if they decide to do it
how to do it when to do it to be able to
engage in a reselling program
i think uh this is a simple bill that
can have a tremendous impact and i thank
you for your time and any
i interpret your questions
comment as being this is enabling
legislation this is most definitely
enabling regis legislation mr sheriff
thank you representative gallagher
so
um
one
constituent concern i heard earlier this
year was about how
the state want to build a new
secure psychiatric facility on the state
hospital grounds and
when i did some research into that
talked with some of the people involved
i asked why they couldn't just
renovate one of
the
existing buildings on the state hospital
grounds for that purpose that i was
currently saying empty and they said the
reason for that is because it's cheaper
to build a new building than it is to
rent to tear down or um to
tear out stuff inside of an existing
building
and um
put put in new stuff so
would you see this bill as helping
helping
um that situation to um
like does it have to be demolition
debris from a completely demolished
building or just like one with stuff
torn out of it
i guess i can't speak to the
construction costs of original versus
renovated buildings but the material
that can come out of it can be
repurposed in other construction
ventures uh something important to make
sure that i mentioned that only
construction licensed construction
companies in the town of the transfer
station can resell their debris to that
transfer station or
homeowners within that town that's a
transfer station overseas or the town
operations themselves you know if the
town decides to renovate a library or
school
so
renovated materials can help reduce
costs
but i can't speak to the cost of new
construction versus old
um as it relates to the hospital that
you mentioned
representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
it is an enabling
legislation isn't and you confirm that
and
my question is
with you know it's an ongoing uh dilemma
or concern in a community
one the landfill then the leaching and
how it affects the water and
all that
are you
is is that an attempt to
reduce the landfill input and arrest it
and moving forward reduce the
debris or reuse repurpose
reuse
you know reinvent
it is exactly the goal to reduce the
amount of solid waste going into a
landfill and
instead of just saying we can't put this
there trying to create ways that can be
economically impacting positively
towns by creating new revenue
business owners by being able to resell
material that they may have spent time
and money on crews to pull the material
out of a building and then they can
value you know in blue slate windows
doors
but it reminds me of the adage um when i
moved to new hampshire that my
brother-in-law said to me which is
land it's the only thing we making any
more of and so
while we can make new doors and windows
we can also repurpose them to preserve
the lands that we are not making any
more of
are you aware of
other innovative ways of looking at
municipal solid waste and converting
that from waste to energy and completely
using net zero
i i am in fact i filed a bill this year
to allow for transfer stations to
optionally engage in a third party to um
create food waste compost and they would
be able to engage with a business that
turns that into biogas or farmers that
turn that into food
feed for their hogs or livestock or
farmers that turn it into organic
uh fertilizer therefore putting less
chemicals in in food
from food waste into their lands for
fertilizing their
crops so yes this is this is all in that
same mindset for me of let's put less in
a landfill and let's make more value out
of the waste that we create one last one
thank you um that's compost the bio
compost and so the other kind of waste
that is non-compostable
debris and also bio waste which is now
incinerated so there is another
technology called the pyrolysis which
combines unsegregated waste
especially solid municipal solid waste
into energy and you know that is another
way of
reducing or repurposing and making
something positive out of it
and not putting it in the landfill
correct and and i'll take that as a
question as yes this would allow
transfer stations to explore
opportunities like that thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um maybe i'm missing it but i don't see
anything in 149 that prevents
towns from already doing this
in your crafting of the bill did you
come across something that prohibits
towns from from doing what you're
proposing
they can collect but they can't resell
without authorization from the state is
what i was told by ols when i asked
specifically because it turns into a
financial transaction that the transfer
station has to be authorized to do right
now they can only take money from you
when you
dump your refrigerator you dump your
you know things that are larger
television
so for them to resell it to be able to
say here are all the doors and we're
gonna price them
they have to be able to be authorized by
the town to do that
and a follow-up
so
in lines
four and five in your bill
you're limiting this to a project being
completed in town or from a general
contracting business which is based in
the town
and i don't know if you had followed the
serious controversy that took place in
claremont
over the past year and a half
that had to do with a business in town
wanting to utilize
the incoming freight rail system
to bring construction debris into
claremont for the purpose of reselling
it now that was a business that was
located in claremont
but it was not using debris generated
in
claremont so would you be um
open to an amendment that kind of
encapsulated that concept here that that
made it clearer that even if you're a
business in town
you can't do this if you're trucking in
or freight training in
hundreds of thousands of tons of of
commercial debris
ex so two questions one yes i would
because it should be focused on new
hampshire businesses and new hampshire
residents and that was the
goal and second in allowing this
optional
enabling legislation take place under
the control of the town select board
they would give those that agency the
sort of the rule-making requirements so
they could stipulate that it's only
construction debris originating but i
would actually have to inquire more
about that but i do agree
and understand your your question and i
would be open if the committee felt that
it was worthwhile
um to amend it that way
thank you representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for indulging um in
another question so this will enable
department of environmental services to
authorize these innovative ways of
reusing repurposing correct it would
allow the towns to engage in creating a
program with their transfer station to
it to work with
landowners homeowners or businesses
based in the transfer station sphere of
influence
just a quick follow-up yes go ahead uh
yeah in nashville we had swap shops you
know we would bring our stuff and people
would take what we didn't have and my
husband would bring back more
uh from you know books and uh stuff that
you know i would tell him don't come
back with more than what you took so
that was uh our saturday ritual
and so um
i'm thinking
you know that was no money exchange
and we had compost they would take the
compost and but we would get
compost back as residents right so this
will enable
the local municipalities
to put value to
my waist or my gar my trash is
somebody's treasure
correct they could decide whether they
want to put a value on it do they want
to create certain aspects that are in a
sort of a swap shop mentality um this
all region originated for me from a
um
a business that was in littleton that
did that they actually took in and
resold
um demolition debris
doors windows but
sometimes they would say to you oh if
you have stuff that you want to trade
out we'll give you a financial value and
we'll write that off the cost of what
you want to acquire
so again allowing the towns to figure
out what's appropriate for their
constituency with the transfer station
to then offer to those
utilizing the program
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i'm wondering i understand that this is
enabling legislation but i'm curious to
know
do you know if there may be
a minimum tonnage or a minimum quantity
that is required by these recycling
outfits in order to
you know
in order for them to accept the recycled
not recycled the the demolition debris
if if the quantity is is is small
will they still take it or do they will
the town just wait till they get a
certain amount or
is it a possibility that it might end up
in the landfill
well the receiver of the debris would be
the town transfer station not a not a
business
a construction business or a
construction vendor would go to the town
transfer station say hey i want to
utilize this
construction demolition debris program i
have a bunch of blue slate
and
you know
i want to get rid of it
they'll put it and instead of charging
them a fee to stick it into the landfill
they'll say we'll put it here
and you don't pay a fee but we get to
sell it we get to create the revenue
from it it doesn't cost you anything to
get rid of it we but we profit from it
yes representative
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question is this not um analogous to
uh transportations collecting corrugated
cardboard and selling it to a recycler
corrugated cardboard glass aluminum they
do it
right some of some of them even do it
with tree waste and and turn it into
chipped wood for their own
um you know
mulching and parks and
and cemeteries but this then expands the
opportunity
follow-up so really all we're saying
here is instead of having to sell
whatever the valuable waste is to a
third-party recycler we can just sell it
at the transfer station to ivy van who
needs a new door
correct they could decide to do that or
if they wanted to work with a business
that did collect renovated doors or
windows and resell them in a shop
somewhere they could do that too again
it gives the town the opportunity to
turn what solid would be solid waste
into potential into revenue
thanks representative
thank you mr taran thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm looking at uh further down section
149 m19 which allows for regionalizat
regional cooperation
i'm wondering if you considered whether
or not see this is limited to towns
should this be amended could this be
amended in some way
where you provide for the regional
cooperation
to allow for each one of those towns
that have signed into that agreement to
be able to do this because my concern is
that if town a adopts this but town b
did not adopt this and was required to
their cooperative agreement might find
them in court saying what are we
supposed to do i may be in the weeds i'm
just wondering if that's something that
should be considered or if you have
considered that um based on a little of
my i'll say my research um
so
some of this came from three of the
towns that i oversee as a grafton two
rep of uh sugar hill franconia and
easton who have a cooperative transfer
station and they actually have a
cooperative board that oversees those
agreements so any
uh development of the program would have
to be
run through the entity that oversees the
transfer station if i remember it
correctly
in there's a representative of each town
on the transfer station board
from the select board so
i think
what you're talking about is sort of
already built into the way
that
multi-town transfer stations already
already
set up
any further questions
seeing none thank you representative oh
i'm representing trip
no i'm just getting ready for sure
oh okay
thank you so much and thank you for your
flexibility this morning
thank you
mr tuthill are you here
come on up
if you please feel free to use those
wipes to clean the area in front of you
or your microphone
if you feel necessary
there we go uh yes my name is john
tuthill i'm from akwas new hampshire in
sullivan county
and a former member of the environment
and agriculture committee
years ago when we were working on solid
waste issues and construction and
demolition debris
um
i had signed up in support of the bill
and not intended to speak but um having
listened to some of the questions and
the conversation i just would like to
offer a couple of points i mean you
don't have to speak if you if you want
to just listen it's okay yeah no i know
um however um
i think a key part of this bill which i
do support is that it is local and it's
opting in by local municipalities and i
think that that is the scale at which we
need to be working right now
so i am concerned about the issue raised
with claremont
the the only city in sullivan county in
a city i've been
much involved with in solid waste issues
over many many years
the
the large-scale proposal for moving
up to five 500 to 800 tons per day out
of claremont towards ohio on rail cars
is exactly the wrong direction
uh the state of new hampshire needs to
be going
there was an application filed with des
for that proposal which was uh never
approved
as has now been deemed denied
administratively but they are back in
claremont currently seeking um
seeking a variance uh to allow this this
use
uh so so the city remains very concerned
uh this bill would fit
uh as it's written now claremont's needs
at the local level any municipality i
think would find this a step in the
right direction
my other concern is with pyrolysis
and that's something that came up
before the pandemic i think in 2018
2019 a bill was passed
out of scitec approved by the house and
senate
which allowed rulemaking
which would support pyrolysis in the
state of new hampshire and set some
standards permissible levels of lead
emissions
uh pyrolysis
basically is combustion without oxygen
so you do have emissions
um
and the
acceptable levels of lead
in
non-waste fuels derived from
construction and demolition debris
were in my view excessively high this is
creating a new exposure pathway for for
lead
and
so i am concerned again about this the
industrial scale
uh and what is actually happening in the
marketplace so far nobody has invested
in a major pyrolysis plant
but back back then there was a proposal
being floated
before legislative committees for up to
a 400 ton per day pyrolysis association
a
pyrolysis operation associated
with a major c d processor down in
epping new hampshire
so those are the two points that sort of
came up for me during the uh the
questions and the discussion well thank
you for having the courage to step
forward and i express you to the
committee are there any questions from
the committee yes representatives davis
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
and and thank you also for bringing up
the claremont
uh issue i think
any
resident of new hampshire that lives
adjacent to or anywhere near a freight
rail line
has to be concerned
about massive transport of construction
debris which is a growing market
and its effect on that municipality in
that region and it's for that reason
that i would like to
explore and ask you if you think an
amendment to this bill would be
beneficial
railroads fall under federal laws and
basically can do what they want but we
don't have to help them
by having a state law
that supports what they would like to do
so i'm so my question is do you think it
would benefit from an amendment that
made it very specific that
i'm not even sure about the wording but
the massive rail transport of
construction debris
masquerading as
sales in a transfer facility is not
allowed
um yes thank you for your question i i
think that
while the existing language
as i read it uh would not present an
enormous risk i think clarifying
language would probably be a good idea
because we have seen this before in
public-private partnerships where
private corporations use municipalities
and this happened in claremont in fact
going back into the 80s
where hundreds of millions of dollars
came out of our region and out of our
county and our sister county in vermont
um
a great detriment to economic
development in our county and
particularly to the city of claremont so
yes i think anything that can be done to
make sure this is focused on the local
on the municipality
and is not simply
supporting a very major market new
hampshire is a major importer of
construction and demolition debris and
this is kind of the disposal bin of last
resort it's where you put something when
you don't know where else to put it
lebanon new hampshire is a model right
now about how to
how to address this particular waste
stream they're doing very good work
and they're doing i think what what this
bill 1122 is trying to begin at least a
discussion about which is you've got to
be doing source segregation and you've
got to be doing it as soon as possible
preferably at the
the construction site the renovation
site or the demolition site right now
it's just coming at us in mixed loads
you don't know what's in it it's very
problematic but anyway yes i would i
would certainly support an amendment
that made it very clear this is local
municipal and it's for the public sector
not the private sector
representative
thank you mr chair um i don't know i
over here
i was the one who brought up the
pyrolysis and i'm very closely involved
with the pyrolysis
technology that the latest one that is
plasmagen pyrolysis which is the
emission is almost net zero and it's
aggregated and it also provides and
pyrolysis ranges from to the difference
between right so the
uh regular incineration versus pyrolysis
ranges 10 times
more
hotter and no oxygen so from that point
of view
looking at pyrolysis where it converts
the waste
totally into energy
and
any byproduct
completely
um environmentally friendly no
no um
toxic
emission or leeching
have you heard of that or are you aware
of this yes i'm very aware of the
technology and of the progress that has
been made pyrolysis has been around for
over a century the old gas tank down at
the end of south main street was
basically a pyrolysis operation very
dirty
it is much cleaner today you are correct
but when you're dealing with elements
like lead you cannot destroy them you're
simply moving them from one place to
another or one medium to another
and that i think is where the problem
comes
because you are generating energy with
pyrolysis plants
so there's obviously the potential for
profit there
my problem really in new hampshire is
the standard we set
for permissible exposures
thank you
are there any other questions
thank you sir i appreciate you stepping
up and entering the discussion thank you
mr graves from nhma
thank you mr chair nate grace for the
new hampshire municipal association i
will be as brief as possible we support
this bill
as the committee comments have indicated
the committee is well aware of
the issue with solid waste we have in
this state i think representative van
summarized the
what this bill would accomplish very
nicely
so i would just re-emphasize that this
is a local option that does have the
potential to reduce some solid waste
raise some funds for municipalities and
potentially provide some resources
for new construction projects through
reuse of old ones i'm happy to answer
any questions anyone have you have
any expertise
or
history
of dealing with the questions that have
come up with pyrolysis and or
waste products from this type of
activity i do not but i do know the
solid waste manager in lebanon new
hampshire and i'm happy to have direct
any committee questions to him yeah well
what i was thinking is representative
egan is going to bring us an amendment
i think that
this warrants
expanding
the topic of that amendment to include
some of the
secondary waste issues that seem to have
come up
i just don't know if you're willing to
maybe work with representative egan or
absolutely okay we i will be in contact
with him today and put him in touch with
uh everyone i know in the waste
management world and i'm sure they'll
come up with a good solution i suspect
this bill will have trouble
at the at its next step if we don't
answer those questions
mr chair yes um i would be happy to work
with uh nsma or representative egan
especially in terms of the pyrolysis
i've done a lot of work with that so i
we'll be happy yes
you're already doing that
go ahead so representative stavis
is already doing that and representative
manchipudi is volunteering to work with
you as well excellent i will send an
email
great thank you so much thank you okay
that concludes the hearing
on house bill 1122
and we are now going to open the next
hearing on
house bill 1155
which is relative to persons elected to
a local school board
rather a local board serving on another
board
yes
mr would you like to
introduce to bill
i would good morning and thank you mr
chairman and members of the municipal
county and government committee
for the record my name is peter teroshan
i'm a state representative representing
rockingham county district 14 which is
the towns of atkinson and plaistow
and before you this morning is the prime
sponsor of house bill 1155
an act relative to persons elected to a
local board serving on another board
the intent of this legislation is to
have the ex-officio member
so
the ex-official member is somebody
that's appointed from the governing
board whether it be the board of
selectmen or
town council whatever it may be called
in the municipality
uh who's appointed to
be liaison to another
committee in that town for example a
budget committee planning board building
needs committee what have you
it would continue to keep that
ex officio
as a member but it would be a non-voting
member that's in essence what the
legislation does
and the reason for this is quite simple
is to maintain a balance of power
between the governing board and the
other boards
for example an ex-official member of a
town's budget committee
can currently vote on town budgets
in warrants with the board of selectmen
and then he can go over the next
official on the budget committee side
and vote for the the same
budget
and warrants essentially getting a
second bite of the apple or second vote
so it gives that individual kind of a
super majority
i believe government works best
when
uh there's a balance between the
branches
of government with full transparency
many of my constituents aren't aware
that
in my town that the next official
can vote and and i've been questioned by
i don't understand why there's a an
extra
member of the committee that's voting i
don't remember voting for him
uh you know for the planning board or
the budget committee whatever it was
and i explained what well
he didn't run for that committee he's
he's a member of the board of select
when they get a
excuse me
uh get to serve as an ex-officio
so
excuse me
in some instances the liaison
that i've seen
in our town and towns around me
has not participated with their
committee for example
they're appointed by the board of
selectmen to be
liaison to their budget committee
they
don't participate at all in the process
so they they lose out on the debate
the research that's done and
really the the work that the budget
committee come that does and then they
show up on
the public hearing day and vote
without being fully informed and
i know a particular member that did that
and while they were doing that they were
texting on the phone the whole time they
had their marching orders of how to vote
and that's what they did and i'm not
saying everybody does that but again
this is a balance of power issue
and to ensure that the person is voting
is fully informed
we certainly want the people that are
voting
to be fully engaged in the process
and if you're
an elected member of that committee and
you're not engaged and you're not
paying attention the details the voters
have a right to
decide to vote somebody else into that
position in the next election
so let me be clear there is a value to
have an ex official member to provide
useful information dialogue for issues
of concern that help work out
differences between two different boards
and again just to reiterate um
again i think it's useful to have an ex
officio
um but to have one that doesn't attend
meetings and then just shows up to be a
robo vote
um
to to get a second bite of the apple i
think is bad policy bad government
there's a further concern
um with the current rsa when you run for
office so at the local level if you
decide you want to run for your board of
selectmen you can't put your name on the
ballot say i'm going to run for the
board of selectmen in the budget
committee or i'm going to run for the
border selectmen and and planning board
that's not allowed because there's a
is a simple reason for that
there could be
a conflict of interest
between you know to be running for two
boards holding two boards on the local
uh level obviously you can run
and be elected to a a local committee in
your town and run and be elected to a
position up here at the state house
so um
with that
keeping that in mind that you can't run
for two boards
and following the same logic
the ex-official member should not have a
vote on the second committee
i ask you to please to consider an otp
on house bill 1155
this concludes my testimony i'd be happy
to take any questions that the committee
may have
yes representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
can you help me understand something
that would apply to where i live which
is a city which is lebanon
where i serve on the planning board
which is an appointed not an elected
position
and we have a representative from the
city council who is elect an elected
official
as a liaison
from the city council to the planning
board and
that person is a voting member
with if this bill should pass would that
no longer be allowed i mean
that person's vote is critical to our
planning purposes
i thank you for the question
representative so um
i i guess one of the questions i would
have um i know we can go back and forth
but if if and i don't know how your town
uh points does does your gut does your
governing board appoint city council
appoints okay
so
the same rule would apply the the
liaison member um wouldn't get a vote
but the planning board members
to clarify
if it doesn't matter if you're an
elected
in an elected position or an appointed
position in that second committee in
this case the planning board
all those members would continue to vote
they were they were appointed for that
purpose the ex-official
can participate in all matters regarding
planning board and be again a go-to
between
your town council city council
to answer any questions they may have so
that you have
good communication back and forth but at
the end of the day um only the
the
appointed or elected positions of that
particular board would have a vote
that's in essence what this does
thank you representative again
then in line six of your bill
should it not say
to which the person was not elected or
appointed
what the intent is there and and i heard
that there was maybe some confusion on
that and i'd certainly be open to to an
amendment
it it means that the um
appointed so in other words
how the words intended to be used in
this languages
if the governing board
appoints the person to another board
then it's a non-voting position if your
governing board appoints
the planning board they certainly would
have a
voting
position so
if that needs an amendment to clarify
that i'd be happy to uh
you know
it certainly would make it clearer for
me although i continue to say that the
the vote of the city council member on
our planning board is absolutely crucial
but
needless to say
regardless of that
i
i find the language a little bit
confusing because it does
say elected
and in at least in our case
we don't have elected officials on our
planning board
right i understand and the reason i used
the
word appointed was to because
there's a there's a couple different
terms that could be used the person
could be appointed by the board of
selection of the committee they could be
their next official member um so
again just to clarify
um
that wouldn't take away the right of a
person that was appointed to do that
board's business to vote
and for that matter if there was a
vacancy in a board an elected board
where that particular board say the
planning board's elected they have
somebody move out of town there's a
vacancy
um
in that in most towns that
committee committee's allowed to pick
their replacement that person would be
appointed and they certainly would have
the right to vote so that's
what the intent is
yes sir
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
uh in my town i'm elected to the select
board
uh from there i am the ex officio by
statute or or as statute allows to the
planning board our seven-member member
planning board
from that planning board i sit on a
three-member subcommittee three-member
because if we had four obviously we'd
have a quorum of the planning board and
we don't want to do that on a
subcommittee
if this bill were to pass would i have a
vote on the subcommittee of three people
so
um
how is this i guess i want to know how
the subcommittee is is um
put together you know what's the process
there if if it was an elected
position or appointed for just for the
exclusive purpose of being on the
subcommittee i would say
a liaison if you were considered the
next official would not get a vote it
would be the same would apply but i
guess it depends on how it's structured
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um
there are different uh descriptions of
uh land use boards and how they are
the makeup of different land use boards
and planning boards um
in particular
have a six-member board plus an
ex-officio
uh governing body member
if the governing body body member
couldn't vote then then you'd have an
even number in your cases and could
easily have nothing pass
and then the other land use boards like
the historic district commission and the
heritage commission
specifically say
that a member of the governing body may
be a member of that board but it doesn't
say anything about non-voting
it's just for the um
during the period of my term
and i don't remember all the other land
use boards but they all reference
uh somebody being a
governing body
member being appointed to the
to those boards so would this now
say that none of those people can act on
any of those
land use boards and therefore
um
leave different boards with an even
number of
votes
i thank you representative for the
question in in
so the answer is this again if we adopt
this language it would change
the
ex official from the governing body in
your town
to have a vote but other members that
are appointed to that land use board
would get a vote in regard to the even
versus odd number
i've been on boards that are even
numbers i think in some respects
it makes us work a little harder which
isn't necessarily a bad thing because
i've been there when we
we end up splitting the vote and we go
back to
[Music]
work out our differences and and pass
whatever we're trying to pass out of
that committee so i understand where
you're coming from it's i guess it's the
same could be said if the governing
board
is an odd number or any other board and
one person doesn't show up that night
you have an even number you're in the
same same spot
all of these boards are described as how
many members you can have
seven or five three three alternates
four alternates depending on the board
so you have to have seven members of a
planning board
and one of them is
a
member of the governing body so
this is this not in direct conflict with
the
previous rsa and or should you be
amending different rsas to get the
the
outcome that you're looking for
thanks again for the follow-up question
well i would suggest the governing board
again if that's the
board that appoints people could appoint
a seventh person there's nothing in this
legislation that would prevent them from
having an odd number so in that case if
you had seven
so you met that requirement the ex
official would be the eighth
but being an advisory only that wouldn't
affect the vote
let me say uh
representative would you agree that
the odd number of votes
while not
required it's probably advised so you
know so that the
the
the committee or the or the subcommittee
doesn't run into thai votes which
which stops
any uh any suggestion for moving forward
certainly that would be a better
scenario
if you're trying to pass something out
you you could stalemate with an even
number but again as as a follow-up to
what i just said um this legislation
won't prevent
the governing board from
from changing that to make sure they
have seven members of that committee
thank you mr chu thank you
representative for taking my question
i i'm not asking about um
any of the rsa
my question is
what prompted you to come up with this
is there a issue that uh you're trying
to address or to me it seems more like a
micromanaging individual local boards or
local appointees
correct or wrong thank you for the um
question uh representative
no it's actually not trying to
micromanage as i mentioned in my
testimony i've had constituents approach
me on that wondering why there was a
person that shows up every now and then
gets to vote that wasn't elected to the
board so this is actually not
micromanaging this is actually
trying to uh ensure that
the boards have um the power to do their
the job they were elected to
without
you know again in essence under the
current situation i use budget because
in an sb2 town budget committees uh pass
a budget in the board of select runner
um
town council um
passes the budget as well so
i would
to think of it another way
um this this
on the local level is kind of like if
some one of the members of the other
body
um here at the state level got a vote
with us in the house and vice versa so
this this is actually to to clarify in
the india and to give
clarity to the
fact that as an as a citizen when you
vote for somebody on a board they do
that job without
giving somebody on another board a
second or third bite of the apple
depending if they're late lays on a x
official to more than one committee that
that's all it's trying to do
um
just thank you for taking a follow-up
it's almost
seems to me to look at i mean each
community has its own appointed or
elected
and uh processes uh
somewhere balanced so are we
looking at bringing the partisanship in
that
whole democratic
process of stalemate down to the local
level that's that's
why i am perceiving this so correct me
if i'm wrong
no thank you representative no that's
not the intent again the intent is to to
balance the power so that the um
the committees involved have
you know the full authority they were
voted into office to
exercise
um
without having one
committee or board having more power
which is in essence what the current rsa
allows
representative
uh thank you mr chair and i have a quick
question and then uh
kind of a follow-up to it um is this
applied to all municipalities meaning
town city village exactly
or is it just two towns
uh thank you representative
to and i i can't tell you exactly how
each uh municipalities is structured but
the irsa that this pertains to any town
that
falls under that rsa this would would
affect
may i have thank you um
in in in my city
um i am we we have a board of aldermen
elected we have a board of education
elected
we have um a liaison from the board of
aldermen on the board of ed they're
non-voting they're just advisory
i am a board of alderman member i'm on
other committees that are appointed
some i'm just liaison to give advice
and to help guide them and others i'm
actually a voting member
and
they choose that for a particular reason
are you saying that you feel
that
i would have an undue influence on that
and i'm not saying me particularly i'm
just saying the position so um would
have an undue influence on the one that
i do get to to vote on
um when it was made up they looked at
all who the stakeholders were and they
wanted all the stakeholders on that
particular committee
so that's i guess my question to you uh
thanks again for the follow-up question
um
i guess the simple answer is
the
if we adopt this language it will um you
mentioned there's several that you're
it's a non-voting so this this is what
that attempts to do you want that we we
want in in
indeed i believe it is good to have that
liaison and that relationship between
the voice communication is important in
any municipality
um but it's again it's balancing off
nothing in this
in this
legislation prevents the governing board
again if they appoint a position to add
other members to that board they can
still do that may have a follow up
um
i i should have clarified and i
apologize for not doing it
so for instance the
one of the um commissions that i'm on
as a liaison and a voting member
does not bring anything back to the
board of aldermen
so when that commission was created they
wanted all stakeholders so a board of
aldermen citizens
different organizations someone maybe
from construction and so on it's
something that doesn't go back to the
board of aldermen but if i read this
correctly
even though i'm a stakeholder in that
and the information is not going back to
the board of aldermen for a final
decision so therefore i'm not getting
two bites of the apple i would not be
able to vote on it though so the board
of aldermen's stake in this or the city
stake in this would not
um
be represented
okay thanks again for the further
follow-up
um
well you you still have the vote with
the border element and so in the
scenario that i painted with the budget
committee versus a border selectmen
that person still like the other members
of the border selectmen vote on the
budget in that
committee
or board
um and the the budget committee votes
their their uh budget and then in most
municipalities what happens is there's
some reconciliation between the two two
boards to work out the differences they
have so um
again i i think it it makes more
transparency and better government
because again i
mentioned that
when citizens don't know that there's
somebody on the board that they didn't
elect they they question their have
questioned me and that again the reason
for the bringing this forward
yeah i i think i'm just not making
myself clear so
maybe if i give the the perfect example
of it is i'm on the board of aldermen
i'm also on the historic district
commission
the historic district commission was
created by the board of aldermen
it does not report back to the board of
aldermen
they just wanted to have a voice on that
commission as well as all the other
stakeholders which are mostly citizens
on on that particular
commission
if i read this correctly i would not be
able to be a voting member on that
historic district
commission
even though
nothing that they do comes back to the
board of aldermen
does that does that clarify a little bit
so it's not like i'm on the board of ed
and where that may come to whatever the
selectmen or the governing body
no you're clear on that and in your
assumption is correct um
with that and you know i understand this
is not with the one you just
the example you gave is not one that
would lend itself to conflict some of
the others i mentioned it is the
conflict is is part of the reason again
for this
excuse me just so this does
take that into this um would stop me
from voting is what i'm trying to say
yes
thank you thank you so much
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking yet another question
i was going to ask you the question
clee just asked about the bite of the
apple
i'll try it in a different way which is
um
would you believe that
on the lebanon planning board
the city council representative who has
a vote on the planning board which is
appointed by the city council
and is listed as part of the duties of
city councilors to serve on planning
board as liaisons
that information never goes back to the
city council for any kind of vote
whatsoever
so the the supposition that there is
undue influence
or
more than one bite of the apple
at least in this case
just is not true
and this and yet this bill would deprive
us of
the the necessary voice that we
absolutely need on the planning board
and it is called for in our city charter
so it seems to me that this bill would
would
contradict many existing municipal
ordinances
and rules for appointing or electing
officials to boards and and i also just
wanted to ask you about
something that you
said about
in response to a question about what
prompted you to put forward this
legislation and you said it was i i
believe you said it was a question from
a constituent
who asked hey what's up with this person
who gets a vote on this board and i
didn't elect them
couldn't the response to that question
had been well actually that person
wasn't elected to that board that's in
your town's charter that that person is
appointed to that board as a voting
member and that's
an appropriate position
what what is the supposition that there
is hanky-panky going on i just don't get
that
thank you for the question and so um
i don't think that's what i i said that
there was hanky-panky going on but it no
it's not in and i did and i did explain
to him
to
my constituents that ask
how it's set up it's not in the town
charter it's in the rsa in fact a lot of
towns from what i understand don't the
um ex official doesn't necessarily
exercise that vote to write because they
feel it's
it's a
again the super majority kind of
situation so
anyway in regard to the one
with your planning board um
again i would not knowing your charter i
really can't answer the question and
stuff to what extent this affects that
other than to say
if you read the irsa that it affects
the uh
and pertains to
towns and in uh committees as reference
in the rsa
thank you
okay for those who have support or
oppose this bill um i'm sorry we have a
couple more folks to testify
um
mr graves from uh
from municipal and uh county government
thank you representative
thank you mr chair and here's the new
hampshire municipal association
we oppose this bill after i've heard the
sponsor
talk about why he wanted the bill i
think that the intent is really
to modify the membership of at least a
specific committee
i don't believe that this bill does that
and i'd like to explain that by using
the example of a planning board so
planning board is created
or i guess i should say a town
legislative body so the town voters have
a choice about how they want to compose
that planning board and that's under rsa
673 colon 2.
if you think of a traditional town with
a select board um
there are two options really either the
planning board is elected or appointed
and it's comprised of some at-large
members and an ex-official member who is
a select board member or administrative
official
and that's all contained within 673
colon 2.
now 672 colon 5 defines ex officio and
that's just the common definition it's
the common definition used in the law
and it it just says you know an
ex-official member is just somebody
who's
elected or appointed to one board who
then serves as a member on another board
um
in in the particular case of a land use
board
like we're using the select board member
is picked by the other select board
members to go serve as that seventh
member on the planning board
um so
when we look at
the bill as written
presumably that would be the person who
qualifies under line four as appointed
to
serving on that other municipal board
and now we'd have a conflict in the law
because rsa 672 colon 5 wouldn't
say the same thing as the new 669 colon
9 hyphen a
now you might also have
you know a official budget committee in
your town
an official budget committee does not
have anyone serve on the planning board
but they might be interested in learning
what the planning board is doing because
you know the planning board might be
redoing the master plan for instance so
the official budget committee might
appoint a liaison to the to the planning
board liaison is just
doesn't have any official role there's
no they don't vote they don't they don't
talk to the board they just get
told hey you're on the budget committee
with us go over there listen to what
they're doing come back and tell us
they might be useful in the context of a
master plan creation because they can go
back to tell the budget committee hey
look here's how we think development's
going to happen in this town
maybe we should consider allocating some
resources in the budget to specific
projects rather than others
um
and so that would just be a liaison um
and that person would have no official
role so already in line four and onto
five is a liaison to another local board
that person already can't vote they
can't even participate in the board
discussion
and then we have the third option
on line four which is serving on another
board
so if you look at again
still looking at the planning board
statutes if you look at 673 colon 5
it says
when may a planning board member serve
on
another board with another planning
board member and it's limited so on
another land use board only one planning
board member may serve but on you know
some other
board um a planning board member may
also serve on that board so
you know you might have a planning board
member who's also
you know on the historic district
commission or something like that
that person isn't necessarily appointed
there or isn't necessarily uh appointed
as an ex-officio to that board or
liaison maybe they're just you know
somebody who was either elected to both
of those positions or appointed to both
of those positions or some combination
thereof
and
under
669 colon 9a this bill is written
presumably that person would have to
figure out
which one of the boards they're serving
on
um as kind of the regular voting member
and which one they now qualify as a
non-voting ex official member and that
doesn't
really make a lot of sense
um
that's how we would read it that's the
advice i would give my members if this
were to pass
um
i think that based on the sponsor's
comments the intent was really to modify
um
some sort of membership on some board
i'm not sure which one um
but i would submit to the committee that
an amendment that looked at that
specifically might be a better option
because it wouldn't interact with all
these other statutes inadvertently
happy to take questions
thank you mr chair thank you mr greece
for taking my question um
i would ask
how would this bill upset the apple cart
you did mention some of the other rsas
it's like a domino effect and so there
are so many changes
it you know there's system that's
working if one particular
instance that it
is not changing the whole
organizational
or whole rsa
might upset so many other
you know
right so
realistically we have two kinds of
boards we have the boards that are
statutorily created and their membership
is defined in statute um so we can't
change those and this may conflict with
that and then we have other boards that
might be created by an existing board so
for example
a select board
might decide to create a board
for the purpose of organizing old home
day activities right there's no
statutory
there's nothing in the statutes about
that but it's a useful board to have
because that board can go out do
everything they need to do and report
back to the select board about what
needs to be done
and how they define the different roles
is is is going to be up to that board um
and they're going to set the rules for
that so they might say hey we want a
select board member on there um you know
as next official member and then we're
going to appoint some people from the
community who are interested some you
know business people whatever the police
chief um
and so those are really the two kinds of
boards we have and again you're going to
run in
run into the situation and at least for
the
locally created boards you probably
could adjust membership to deal with
some of the issues that arise but for
the statutorily created ones um
i don't know how to resolve the conflict
yes representative
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
grace for taking my question so if i
understood you correctly and please tell
me if i did
we have a resident in our town who has
opted to run for the
library trustees and has also opted to
run for the water commission
do i understand that if this bill were
to pass or you know this was next year
and this would have happened that person
would have some
would not
be clear which position that person
could vote
correct so
you know reading just the relevant
language of the bill is written an
elected member of a local board
commission committee etc
who is also serving on
another board in the same jurisdiction
she'll be a non-voting ex official
member of any such local board to which
the person was not elected so it's not i
mean that doesn't really make
sense
because
you kind of have to presume that they're
not they're appointed to some board
they're not elected to it um
so i'm not exactly sure how that would
operate but
my advice to to my members would be
you can't serve on more than one board
in the possibility that your vote
wouldn't count and we wouldn't know that
until it was challenged in court
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
um
so the
the boards that are created statutorily
um could a select board appoint the
ex-officio to all the boards
if
i'm sorry i'll clarify that a little bit
say the boards are set up five seven
three or whatever odd numbers
and then the uh select board will come
along and say okay
we are going to appoint ex-officios to
those different boards
now
and they appoint them as a non-voting
person just say for example
for informational purposes only
and i think it would be helpful in that
case do you agree
i i
i just want to be clear on terminology
here so
for example under the budget committee
there are multiple options uh for ex
officio so each
the the select board for example would
appoint ex official who just operate as
a normal budget committee member but
under a board that doesn't have an ex
officio specified there would be no
ability to appoint an ex-officio they
could appoint a liaison which would not
be able to participate in discussion
unless that other board allowed them to
and would not under any circumstance be
allowed to vote so you know the
select board might appoint an ex
official to
um
the zba for
i'm sorry a liaison to the zba for
instance
they would be able to hear what the zba
is doing they wouldn't be able to vote
they would never be able to participate
in the discussion unless for some reason
the zba invited them to do so so that's
all statutorily defined and that's why i
think a cleaner option if the goal is to
do something like change the budget
committee membership would be to look at
that statute and change the relevant
language there
yes
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
grace for taking my question
um i guess my question is around
jurisdiction and your opinion on that
and i'll give you a specific example i
chair a
statutory
commission for the state and
four of our members of that commission
as defined in that statute are appointed
by their town council or boards of
selectmen
to serve on the commission
so with and actually two of them are
here today so
now with that
if this were to pass would they be
not allowed to vote on the commission
even though it's a statewide commission
in the statute setting that up which was
hb 737 in 2019
they
they have to be appointed they're only
representing that local jurisdiction
i i don't believe that would be a
conflict because i believe this only
pertains to local boards
and i i also want to clarify something
that representative clee had mentioned
earlier
i
i she mentioned um something about the
city charter um and how that was set up
i should have mentioned earlier that
there's a potential conflict with city
charters as well but that's going to be
an individualized basis based you know
there are 13 cities they all have
different charters with different
provisions so
i just don't know off the top of my head
which ones have ex officios and which do
not
thank you okay thank you
thank you
on this bill
we had uh three in support and 34
opposed
and on the last bill hb 1122 it was uh
30 support zero opposed
okay so at this point
i'm going to ask the committee
yes
um i'd just like to note that
i had told a constituent that
to be here for
a hearing on my bill at 11 30 and she's
currently waiting here so um
just i want to make sure that um
we be mindful of that when deciding
how long to take before
we get to my bill so she's not waiting
too long
and recycling yeah
okay i'm gonna we're gonna take a short
lunch i'll ask everybody to be back here
at uh
at 12 35
uh and is there anybody let me see a
show of hands anybody in the audience
here to a present
to hear house bill 1617
okay i would ask you to come up after
i recess the meeting to speak with me up
right up here
we're in recess
well
i will talk to you later
where are you going with some other
thing you'll share with us yeah i want
to give these people an opportunity
well thanks for coming to testify
the good news is we're going to
give you an opportunity to testify
the bad news is the sponsor of the bill
wants to withdraw the bill
which at this point
i can't personally withdraw it but you
should know
that when it comes time to testify on
this bill
in front of the house
when the sponsor says kill this bill
99 of the time it gets killed so want
you this is kind of an effort thing how
much effort you're going to put in this
testimony you're here so i'm going to
give you an opportunity to testify and
we'll take we'll take the appropriate
notes but just know that the sponsor has
asked that the bill
i think everybody's here position okay
i can certainly register that in our
documentation
um okay
at this point i hope you didn't have to
drive a long way to come and hear that
the bill is getting killed
so we probably should not stay
you can if you want but
you're not there's not going to be
there's not going to be any fireworks
okay
if you promise
leave each other a business that
probably
needs the time thank
you that's right go down tell them lunch
is on me
so
well
hey jim yes sir i have uh
some coffee stained research
people had some questions about when a
fiscal note is required
oh yeah so this kind of you want to pass
that around that kind of answers that
and so i i'm glad you did that because
we got an answer yesterday
so i also found out then from paul
and this is this has changed our opinion
that in order to require that fiscal
note after the fact that he would begin
it would require
a vote of the full committee in
executive session
to get that
our opinion was our collective thought
was the fiscal loan is not going to
change our mind on the four bills that
we are considering
so it's probably not the prudent idea
but if we were going to waste the time
exactly so
we're not gonna we're not gonna go that
way but this is this is helpful thank
you
you're welcome to make a copy of that
but i need that coffee stand back
you can have the coffee stay like 14
14 44 i'll make note of that okay thank
you
when did we hear that
oh yeah
yeah the the uh we don't
necessarily post the exec sessions
so it's so it's inconvenient for you
guys
but what did you number did you say
1-3
i will yeah as soon as i look at my
notes for it
1507.
yes
this had a lot of folks
speaking in favor
i mean we haven't even heard it yet
right but the people that came i said
if you want
to speak uh
openly
we'll hear it so you don't have a wasted
trip well that was very nice of you to
do that because they decided to submit
paint cards instead they all are
opposition girl in
and as i said to my friend richard over
there i said there was one time where
you said that other people should be
poised upon their petars
yes
and i mean that in the nicest way have
you ever heard
no better way to clean the bottom of the
boat
we're not getting the same volume
it's a feeling of inadequacy
clyde was here
than today
that year i think we had something like
eight freshmen on the committee that
year yeah
me
um just newbies to the house
a guy that
always told those bad jokes
oh max mac up max
max
uh
ready when you are
okay 1172 please uh please thank you mr
chairman and thank you members of the
committee i
am ivy vann hillsborough 24.
i'm here to introduce house bill 1172
which does in fact have a finance note
what this bill does is it says that
while current statute requires that
towns and all jurisdictions provide
recycling and composting facility for
people who live in the town
individual
managers or owners of uh
housing are not required to do that i
don't have to have a compost pile at my
house if i have a triple i don't have to
provide composting abilities for my
tenants and uh the purpose of 1172
is to
make
it uh mandatory
for
public housing
to provide abilities for the tenants of
that public housing facility to have
recycling and composting available
for them so that not everything goes
into a dumpster
and so it says each town so this
it
requires that residents of public
housing located in the town have access
to a composting and waste recycling
facility
and i understand that that the purpose
of the bill was to make it so that there
was not single stream
trash
at public facilities
and i've now told you all i know about
this bill
well thank you thank you you did very
well the the
the level of support for this bill is
for in support 12 opposed
and we still don't have anybody but
natchez uh why don't you come up and you
can testify we're still waiting for the
sponsor to show
thank you mr chair maj graves for the
new hampshire municipal association we
oppose this bill
just for the record we do want to be
part of the
landfill issue solution
we certainly know there's a problem we
know that it's going to affect the costs
for municipalities and for taxpayers and
we understand some compromises are going
to have to be made down the way
as far as this bill goes
i would suggest the committee that it's
premature
at the moment
their might be some debate over the
authority of municipalities to provide
uh
compost facilities and i say that
because of the
existence of hp 1402 which will make a
local option to collect compost and
that's a bill that we are supporting
um
and at present most municipalities don't
actually have a composting facility so
even if you were to require them to
collect compost at a public housing
facility
the result of that would be it would get
landfilled anyway um and that sort of
defeats the purpose
um
so
i think until we have something in place
that has more
um
adopts sort of a broader statewide
approach to composting or we look at
that in more detail
um i think it's a little premature to
start on this end of things
because just simply because there just
isn't this this ability to do anything
other than landfill this material at
this moment in time
i'm happy to take questions
so
you uh you believe it's premature
because we don't have a
an approach that
is statewide well i i would assume the
purpose of having a compost
facility or
starting to collect materials for
composting would be to make compost
which then could be
sold used on agricultural fields
whatever the case may be
we're missing the middle step we
you know we might start collecting it at
public housing for instance um
but
it we don't have anywhere in the middle
for it to go
and that's where we are at this stage
any questions for the nhma yes
yes
thank you mr chair thank you uh for
taking my question um my question is um
i want to phrase it in the form of a
question um there's two parts to it one
is the composting and waste recycling
you know as a city we have a recycling
um and we have had recycling since uh
1989 when it was a pilot and now it's a
curbside pickup
in nashua we also have a private
composting where individuals pay and you
know it picks up and it's
it's working very well
for
me personally in terms of and i've
been able to get more of my neighbors
you know from nhma
you've
talked about opposing anything that is
state-wide or
state-mandated is it only for zoning and
housing or is it any uh
policies that
comes down from the state so the
municipalities don't have the option
so
our policy really boils down to
really two
two things one it either takes away
local control so there's currently local
authority to do whatever it is
or two it's going to cost the
municipality money
so
something like zoning would take away
local control
whereas
you know some sort of state mandate for
municipalities to provide
some specific service is going to cost
them money
as well as take away the local control
of whether they want to do that or not
and that's what that basically is what
it is i mean our policies are much
longer than that but that's what it
boils down to
follow up mr chair yes go ahead
thank you so um
in that case you know currently
different municipalities and
different communities are doing
different things
and if there's a good uh program there's
a good a model that's working in one
community
how do we spread that across the state
or across other communities what kind of
incentive is there or what's the
mechanism well so for for waste uh for
example you know we have
few landfills in the state and the
information that i've received from des
is that essentially they're filling up
and they're going to fill up
over the next decade or so and then
we're going to have to figure out where
we send our waste and if we send it out
of state it's going to be much more
expensive it's going to be more
expensive for
you know the municipalities who are
obviously going to pass that on to the
taxpayers
so we're trying to think of solutions to
not do that
part of that may be composting i'm not
an expert at
everything
[Music]
and
so
you know when we can expand
a recycling programs and we expand reuse
programs when we can expand things that
are going to lower
the speed at which we're filling those
landfills
it's going to save us money
and therefore it's something that we can
support
um so that's why i suggest this is
premature because it's possible
we're going to see widespread adoption
of composting as a local option there
might be some sort of state incentive to
do composting i know that that's
something that vermont has has looked at
has done
um
and i you know i don't know the
economics of that but i'd be certainly
interested to hear more about it um and
if that's something that that works out
that can you know save us money we
support it
since you brought up vermont um i
happened to
straddle between the two place a lot
more more recently because of
our first grandchild and uh so in that
you have you know not only that
they have
zero
uh waste
in the garbage you can't put it has to
go compost either you do locally or city
run or state and also no plastics in
there you know so there's a lot of
uh
spokes to the wheel
absolutely and you know and so
in independently doing it or
collectively doing it
is a whole different ballgame how the
wheel can roll right so from that angle
i think all these things coming together
the waste management the construction
waste and this would be so wouldn't you
believe that this has to be looked
together
i i agree i think there since we are a
small state i think that we're going to
have statewide solutions that we're
going to look to as i mentioned in the
beginning there there are going to be
compromises that need to be made simply
because it's in the best interest of of
the state and the state's ability to you
know deal with this issue because it's
not like we're going to get rid of waste
altogether
representative tripp
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh
my first problem with this bill is
i'm not really sure what the
meaning of public housing is could you
provide that
i do not have a definition of public
housing
all right could i have follow-up please
uh i i believe there's a
requirement in the constitution that
says that
the
legislature can't pass any laws that uh
uh
increase cost
or are unmandated or unfunded uh cost
uh do you think there'll be a
infrastructure cost to
provide composting
so i believe you're referring to article
28a
which
would prohibit these new and new
program costs on top of municipalities
i think that is a legitimate concern in
this particular case
and in addition this is in part why
suggested uh that this this bill is
premature because
it's possible that the state comes up
with a solution in the next several
years
where
they can profitably uh
make and use compost so for example one
of the things we've been doing at
wastewater treatment facilities
is
the solids have been turned into
a form of compost more or less and that
has been
able to offset some of the costs of
operating the wastewater treatment
facility
because that has been able to be sold to
farmers
[Music]
there's an issue at present about um
about
you know chemical compounds like pfas
and whether those those are
and how exactly those interact with with
the
those materials
in the in the future it's possible that
we'd have a situation where
um collecting compost makes sense for
the state and for municipalities because
it's going to offset some costs
associated with waste removal
but it's really hard to say because as
we've seen with the recycling market
when china stopped accepting a number of
plastics and other materials from
non-chinese sources
we saw that basically the recycling
market collapsed and we saw a lot of
costs go into that and a lot of those
materials had to be
landfilled
we've seen
upswing in domestic recycling
facilities since that time
and a number of items which weren't
previously profitable such as glass are
now profitable
and assisting to offset costs so
i couldn't predict the market it's
possible that in the future it would be
something that wouldn't cost money um
but at present as i mentioned there's no
there's no middle in in this system um
so even if you were to set up this
composting facility or composting
collection
this material would end up being
landfilled so essentially all you're
doing is putting up another dumpster or
another bin
um
and that doesn't really seem to
accomplish i would assume what the what
the sponsor's intent is or
really uh offset the
offset the costs here
well thank you does it make sense
to
well i'll come back to that
representative man
i'm sorry
oh
that's okay thank you mr chair and and
thank you mr grace for taking my
question you mentioned earlier um hb
1406.
if that bill were to pass would that
would it make this bill in your opinion
unnecessary
um
well they're very different bills so hp
1402 would just be a local option to
collect compost
that's
currently not in the waste management
statutes
it appears from what representative
manjapuri has said that some
municipalities are doing that
and i've certainly heard that myself
so i'm not
sure if
you know why that's needed um i don't i
don't recall from the from the hearing
but at least it would make it explicit
that they can collect compost and
presumably it'll be the same with
anything else is that you'd have
a
number of essentially small producers
we'd all have our little compost bin
we'd all bring it to the transfer
station or wherever and then
collectively would make a lot of compost
and then then the municipality could
sell that apply that to you know give it
to the county farm whatever they're
going to do with it
okay and um
follow-up yes mr chair thank you
with this bill it
it also includes waste recycling access
to
waste recycling do you know how many new
hampshire municipalities
don't currently do not have waste
recycling
facilities
and it and if not do they are there
access
or do they rely on private waste
recycling
uh
programs that their
their residents can use so every
municipality minimum has to provide
access to a transfer station and
different transfer stations are
different rules so i can tell you from
my own uh my own experience i used to
live in sugar hill and sometimes i'd use
the franconia one which i was supposed
to use and sometimes i'd use a little
one because that's where i worked
and the different facilities took
different materials and
presumably they sent them out to
different markets um
i assume the same thing would be would
be the case you know kind of across the
board okay thank you
thank you representative representatives
davis
thank you mr chair i actually had a
question for for you as the chair
now that the prime sponsor of the bill
is here um i'm i'm wondering if we could
hear from him because i have several
unanswered questions about
meanings of terms in this bill
that that weren't that have yet to be
sufficiently answered
okay representative gallagher
um yes so yeah sorry for um
yeah so or well is
is
mr gray's done or can i take do you want
to sit at the head as a sponsor um yes
please
so
hi um
yeah sorry again for um i guess i
shouldn't have
made that request
before lunch break after i didn't
realize it was going to be a full lunch
break and i didn't realize that
or
how crowded it would be
in there
so
anyways
yeah i
am
eric gallagher
um
i represent
concord ward 6
which is merrimack county district 15.
um
i have this bill
hb1172
event who
require compost and waste recycling to
be made available
to residents of public housing so
yeah as i said i represent concord
downtown concord
which is
a pretty urban district
which has a number of
public housing projects in it
and
currently
the way it works is that public housing
projects
for wasting them
waste disposal just have
a single dumpster for
throwing trash in
wow
so i happen to i happen to live in
public housing myself and
the way i solve it is
to bring my compost and recycling over
to my parents house who live a few
blocks away
now other people who live in my
apartment building don't necessarily
have
family who lives nearby though
um
so if they want to compost or recycle
and don't know
anyone around
um
that
and don't know anyone around that they
can bring theirs over to then they're
pretty much just
out of luck
so
i i
um
i
requested this bill to uh
give
residents of public housing
access to
compost and recycling um
so as for the specific language um
so
um it says
um each town um
uh
um
i'm assuming they went with that just
because um
that's what the
section is about is about towns i
intended it for it to
apply to all municipalities um both
cities and towns so if you think that an
amendment um
to change
town to municipality would
help things i would be open to that
um
so as far as having access to a compost
or waste recycling facility
my thinking there
wasn't like it doesn't need to be an
entire big building or anything
like
my thinking was just basically
that
public housing agencies
would
then
add at make make a second dumpster
available
for people who want to separate out
their
recycling compost from their trash or
if there's only room for one dumpster
like put just put a divider in it or
something
um
so
yeah i um
in talking with some people
about the bill um
i've had some interest
from
the environmental perspective just
because i know
um a lot of people
the forest lake people for example
want to
improve waste management policies
um
in this state that's
and yeah well i i think this bill will
do that that's not actually where i was
originally
coming from though i was mostly just
seeing
this as
a bill to improve quality of life
for public housing residents
you know
to let
public housing facilities be
cleaner and
more orderly so
my my neighbors who
want to
recycle and compost can do so
um
so
that's my bill and i'll take any
questions
representatives
yes thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
so when you refer to public housing are
you are you referring to subsidized
housing yeah um so
like um
um
the concord housing
authority um
accepts section eight
um
section eight payments i'm pretty sure
how how it works um
so um
and my thinking is that
since it's public this state
um
the state has a say
in dealing with them
so therefore that's the um
that's the grounds for being able to
set conditions for
standards of living in them
bear with me while i try to formulate
this question
is there anything in existing law that
prevents
residents of subsidized housing
from
composting or using
treatment facilities
well
or is it just a it's a financial
hardship or a logistical hardship i'm
trying to get at what the
specific problem is
it's more the financial and logistical
part that's the
issue like
you know at
my apartment building
so my parents are able to compost
because they have a backyard and
um
they have a garden that they can spread
the compost in
my apartment building though does not
have any backyard or any green space
around it so there's not really any
place to put compost
so yeah if people wanted to compost here
they
um
like pretty much lonely space available
would be
the sidewalk which is not an appropriate
place for compost
and
as for
um
as for the recycling part um
yeah there is a recycling con place in
concord that
um
that
residents could take their recycling to
but um
well a lot of
you know it being public housing
a lot of the residents are poor and
don't necessarily have cars
like
um and
you know i i i don't have a car myself i
walk most places around the city and i
see a lot of my neighbors
my neighbors um also get everywhere by
walking too so
um
yeah our
um as far as i know
our local recycling center is out on the
heights
which and in a location that is not
along any of the
public
bus lines that are
available
for residents in the city so
if someone without
if someone without a car wanted to
get out to
get out to the recycling center
um even if they did take the bus they'd
still have to then
walk a ways
to get to it after their final bus stop
and
that that's
that's basically prohibitive to
anyone actually doing that
thank you so just a brief follow-up
oh maybe not so brief so as i read um
and 17 it's clear to me
that reducing
input into the waste stream and
composting has been identified by this
body
as a state interest compelling state
interest
and something that new hampshire wants
to do
so it seems to me that
providing access
to all new hampshire residents
to
composting and recycling facilities is
of critical importance and it's
disturbing to me to hear
that
there is a group of people
that are effectively disenfranchised
from that access
um so i so i'm actually um
i'm i'm wondering if
trying to turn this into a question mr
chair
um
i i'm wondering if you might
want to reference that in your bill
by by making a small amendment that just
refers back to the the state adopted
policy
that this is a goal
that the legislature has set out in law
and as a law it should be
abided by and accessible to all citizens
regardless of
their situation
um can you
um provide a reference or like what what
rsa number i should or where this goal
it's 149. oh okay previously
um in 149
title 10 public health chapter 149
and it's um
m11
the very beginning is the public benefit
section
um so
yeah i can
um
i can i can ask oles to i was planning
on going by there
afterwards anyways um
so yeah i can ask them to include a
reference
to that thank you
with regard to your
comment about where's the proper place
to recycle
right up the local sidewalk was
obviously not a good place
my town
provides
a compost barrel
for the residents it's about
three feet wide maybe three and a half
feet tall and it has all the different
vents and so forth you need to use for
the compost to actually generate
because you certainly want to didn't
wouldn't want to dump a bunch of garbage
on the sidewalk or even in the backyard
because it will it will attract
uh
undesirable
small four-footed friends or
larger ones too like bears yes
so uh would that
be a solution if the local community
could provide compost
facilities in terms of maybe a barrel
yeah i think i think a barrel would
count as a facility if you'd like
an amendment clarifying that um i could
get i could include that in what i asked
of
ols
if the thought is perhaps that would be
cost prohibitive for the
for the individual
it's about 70 dollars for the barrel and
i would imagine
uh you could you could
on some type of a campaign you could go
around and convince
local townships to maybe donate those
barrels where people ask for
but uh
yes every representative
oh i'm sorry representative powell i
missed you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my question pertains
to line four in in the use of the word
access
it's unclear to me what the definition
is of that word and and also the
implications and it may have already
been
spoken to in part but would you agree
that
the language in the bill and the use of
the word access
is is unclear at this point
and perhaps that needs to be worked on
um
yeah i mean
i i agree that the word
access can be kind of weasely sometimes
like you see that
health care debates to how there's a
difference between providing
access to health care and health care
itself
so um
the thing is here i'm not really sure of
what language would be better though so
if you have a suggestion of
um
some word to use instead of access i
would be open to that
um
like
when i'm thinking
access
i'm thinking like
uh a a dumpster in the apartment complex
that i can put my recycling in
that's what i'm thinking of what i'm
thinking of
um
for access
representatives davis
i'm sorry
majaputi i'm sorry
just opposite side of the room
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
i was um
i want to give you a little bit i was
having a conversation with ned grays
from new hampshire municipal association
about
some communities doing a
decent job of
you know composting and waste recycling
and for example nashua has
and
you know
per day nashua
uh
collects
250 tons of waste
out of which 50 tons is from just
residential
this is in addition to we have curbside
recycling
and a private
composting
that you know
our household
recycles or compost
over 2 000 pounds of food waste
in one year 2 000 pounds of food waste
just by collecting in a bucket and i
hear you and uh you know grow nashua i
would
recommend go look at grow nashua and
they have really expanded which is a
public private partnership where they do
the curbside pickup of
composting
and then
bring their compost back and they also
have public gardens where they give
people who don't have space to grow
their own vegetables
so there's a lot of different innovative
and this is a critical need
uh in our state and it is also a
thing that's important especially with
the
coveted
uh situation where we have more waste
but just sticking with waste recycling
and composting our neighboring town have
you
had a chance to look at what
vermont is doing
that is
does a lot of curbside
and was that something that you
looked at to see how every
citizen
in the state has access to it
so state-run program
the thing about um
curbside recycling
is
that
um
yeah concord does have curbside
recycling
and um works for
households
where as like um
a single family home or even like say a
duplex or fourplex or something
but for the bigger apartment buildings
like the one i live in it's it's like 10
floors with 10 units on it per floor so
if we put out a curbside recycling
bucket for
each separate
unit in
our apartment building
there
wouldn't be enough
room for all of them um
on the curbside
so
that's that's why it kind of needs to be
that that's why i there's there are
situations where i'd see it needs to be
um more centralized than everyone having
their own um
curbside units
sorry follow-up that i'm not saying each
unit have their own bin but in
nashua if there is a multi
unit dwelling
they have a recycling uh
just like you have trash
what is it called the big
blue stuff there's a dumpster dumpster
sorry thank you
dumpster
you know you have green dumpster for
recycling yeah so uh you know and in
yes single family home have a lot more
options
and if we can offer and that also
composting having a bin
compost bin right next to the dumpster
to bring just that that would really
help in terms of have you looked at
those kind of options um yeah
i think
that i i think those kinds of options
could qualify
um for this
um
so yeah i i am aware of
i i am aware of programs like that
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question i
think i want to follow up on uh
representatives davis's comment about
the using the word public housing and if
you mean by a housing authority
and
if so the housing authorities have
a certain
rules that they have to
provide safe housing for
standards for you know standard of
living
so would
would a town like mine that has a
curbside
both trash and
recycling
would that housing authority
or could the residents of that housing
authority
you know
petition for please use this
rather than making it a state law or
state law to ensure that it happens
i mean yeah
theoretically
residents could petition for that but um
it's
difficult
um
it
it it can be difficult sometimes for
residents of
public housing to
um
to do things like that a lot of times
when interacting with the housing
authority you know it's always
it's a one-way street where they're
always like
the ones asking
you to be the ones to
um
supply these proofs supply these
verifications so you can continue living
here and whatever and people don't
really realize that
um
they can
make
requests
back of the housing authority
so um
this is kind of
my
my um
approach to doing this by legislation is
so that way
they don't necessarily have to do so
themselves so it's to speak up for them
on
their behalves
yes representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
i understand from a previous comment you
made that the use of the word town will
will be amended to include to
as municipality well um if you if you
think that makes sense um
are are you um requesting that are you
saying that yes it doesn't i should do
that well i'm just saying it may be a
flaw in the bill
because um i i've worked on other bills
but municipality is like the
the the given term to refer to
a uh
a you know a a a governing district i
guess it's city or town let me offer
this uh
i've run into this before and i've
gotten
clarification that
the terms town municipality
city
village district are all interchangeable
okay so use of town would include the
city of concord okay
um
and then as a follow-up to the question
representative power asked
regarding the word access i also have a
question on that i'm interpreting from
your response that that is
restricted to on-site
or would it would have would a resident
of public housing
because they could perhaps have access
to a facility a few miles away
that that would fulfill your intent or
your intent is strictly to provide
on-site
um yeah my intent was for it to be on
site um i can
it um
yeah i can have the amendment include
those words if you think that would be
helpful
right
or
or do you or
do you not want that
well i'm just trying to understand the
your intent okay
yeah yeah i would prefer
i would prefer it to be on-site
okay just because
yeah if it's something miles away for
people who don't have cars
that might be difficult to get to okay
and then follow it
okay please
yeah and and then getting back to the
point about the your intent in the bill
um you've described
that this would apply to public housing
because
of the density of the residents and the
the lack of space
for them to do their own composting on
site but would you agree that that may
also occur for other types of housing
that may not be public
but
maybe in a dense area of a community
where there isn't any space so
would this
only apply to those
housing units like that that are
publicly subsidized or managed well
yeah i agree that those other
dense housing developments ought to have
these options available to them
too um i just wasn't quite as sure
if that's
a regulation we can actually do though
you know i
the reason i kept it restricted to just
public housing is
because well it's public it's something
that the government already has a hand
in
um
and
when it comes to
having the government have a hand in
other things
that it doesn't already have one in like
i mean yeah we could do that but it
would probably
make the
legislation a lot harder to pass
and i i
not sure if we i'm not just not sure if
we have the authority
to
extend it to anyone besides
places we have jurisdiction over okay
thank you thank you i'm a little
concerned about the
maybe the terms and definitions you
might be using right now
when you're collecting your data on on
this issue
i've heard a lot of discussion about
recycling
i think you you would have to agree that
composting and recycling are two very
different things
if you talk about curbside pickup or
recycling that happens maybe every week
or every other week
composting is when you put things
into a bin to compost it you usually
want them to stay there a good two or
three months for the
for the organic process to
be conducted if you're taking it you're
taking eggshells and celery stalks and
and
apples
in the
in the dumpster that's not composting
you got to put you got to put them in a
compost heap
and let it rot
rot down to a level that your parents
for example could use and spread in
their garden i'm sure your parents
aren't spreading banana peels in their
garden
so
um
i just want
you to
do you understand the uh
i don't mean to be
rude about this but do you understand
the difference between recycling and
composting yes i i do understand the
difference um i i keep my compost and
recycling separate um
and um
you know the that i would assume that
under this legislation they would be
handled
separately um
the reason i put them together
is well just they're both
they are they are both
uh very important
they're very different
yeah um
and well they're they're they're in a
related subject area um
so
yeah um
i i
the the point is to have
both be available like they don't that
yeah um
when implementing it
they would require separate treatment
but i'm
not really
sure that
it's necessary
to specify that though like i i would
think the fact that
compost and recycling are separate
things would just kind of
be something that
um
would be something that people
implementing this would realize
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question additionally i have a
concern with um another word in the bill
on line five where you
use the word facility
to me that's
unclear based on your testimony and your
intent of the bill
could you um further clarify facility
because to me the word facility is not
necessarily a dumpster
or a container that was that was one of
the ones i was thinking of
um
that's one of the ones i was thinking of
amending um
uh
i i do
think that yeah facility
should probably be
replaced and i'll include that in the
amendment
okay thank you very much
representative a lot of hard work here
and i think probably still some more to
go
yeah um so yeah i have a neighbor so if
she could
testify next
is that is this for virginia yes yes
virginia please join us up at the front
table
and uh
please note that we have some hand
sanitizer
if you want to use it i might need that
and and you can wipe the microphone too
if you want
do excuse me to sound ignorant do i just
put this right on it right right on it
all right
and whenever you're ready go ahead and
begin
when i spoke to
mr gallagher i did tell him
i'm not getting paid to take the garbage
out of the kennedy building
my father was a drill sergeant
and my dad would have felt there are
things that you do that are your civic
responsibility
it is appalling to me the number of
people
that take whatever amenities we have in
the kennedy building for granted
i'm only paying true 17 a month for a
one-bedroom
apartment unit with all the amenities
i even got my shots
they turned it into a vaccination clinic
in there i got the covered shots in
there for god's sakes good job
um
different things happen people come to
visit somebody
some people are in there when they're
not supposed to be
anything's possible in there
the case in point would be thanksgiving
weekend i carried out three huge garbage
bags
of food garbage out of the mail room
because somebody obviously
had come for a visit and didn't know
what to do so they just drop it in the
mail room excuse me this is a john f
kennedy building the mail room you put
junk mail in the waste can you don't put
two gallons of milk
okay i didn't want to do it
but somebody's got to do it
and different ones i'll say can you give
me a hand and i'll go i don't mean that
type of a hand
can you help me a little bit with the
price tag on the grocery bags and i buy
the cheapest grocery
garbage bags that they
offer at demoulas
it's appalling the people that think
they're entitled to something for free
you really don't get anything for free
in life
but anyway i'll be 74 in may
and as long as i have my boyfriend the
cane and i'm strong enough to
carry the garbage out i'm doing the mail
room and i'm doing the laundry room too
by now some of the younger men in the
same age as mr gallagher here
all of a sudden
10 days in a row i didn't carry one bag
out
they took it out
they get it
actions have to speak louder than words
i can see the compound
compost part of it
but like eric was saying
you can't put compost on this damn
sidewalk
there has to be a place
to put it a way to reference
the problem
um
i have a big mouth and i hope it's
neither a boy or a chore to listen to me
i'm grateful that i have a place to live
and i have an address and i'm not a
homeless person
we have homeless people that sneak in
there from time to time
and there are problems in there the big
boss man of the building thomas he says
to me now if you see anything please let
me know
i see more than i want to know about
there's people
selling drugs in there
and i don't mean just marijuana there's
people selling heroin in there
and i see everything i'm like the
socially
detached retina of society
but i don't want to be labeled a
troublemaker so unless it's really bad
i keep my mouth shut
well thank you so much for coming up
here and sharing your experiences with
us it's quite refreshing
to hear someone like you that is
chipping in and helping and
making your
your
building
compadres like mr gallagher a little
more comfortable in their space so thank
you for doing that well thank you for
saying that and
what was i going to say there's one lady
named pam i think pam is 10 years
younger than me
i might have this
but knock on this i don't have diabetes
i can't stand to look at her feet
and she's having trouble so i carry the
garbage up what are you going to do
you you do the best you can day by day
right right and i'm sure you've heard it
all in in your meetings in here
and uh
it's time for me to get up out of the
chair
thanks again for your inputs we
appreciate it very much thank you
yeah i need my boyfriend
in this uh testimony today we've heard
seven people in support of this bill
of it and two are neutral
we haven't one more bill on our docket
and that is
house bill 7 16 17.
i'm sorry um
i'm going to close the hearing on 1172.
i'm going to open the hearing on hb 1617
which has some special circumstances
the
sponsor of the bill has contacted me and
likes to wants to with wants to withdraw
the bill
which you really can't do that we're
this far along
but
it's probably not a good idea for us to
put a lot of energy into it because
what'll happen is when it gets to the
floor
the sponsor will will recommend that it
be itl then the bill will disappear yes
representative
sure you do that
yeah that'll that'll give us a little
frosting on the cake
i'd rather not
we're going to have so much executing to
do soon this will be a three minute exam
i i committed to some people that would
not be doing any executing today
yes ma'am go right ahead thank you
chairman dolan and thank you members of
the committee i am here to present house
bill 1617 an act relative to housing
projects of the community development
finance authority and establishing a
committee to prevent state subsidies for
housing development that is not income
sensitive
this bill's prime sponsor is
representative adjutant from grafton 17
and uh i received a communication from
uh the representative that he that the
bill is not drafted as drafted does not
represent his intent so
he asks us to itl it when we get to the
executive session
thank you very much
so uh
hb
is now
closed
now uh we as a reminder remember that
this coming week we have some hearings
scheduled but we may be doing some
executing which won't be scheduled and
you won't see it in the calendar
but what i'll do
along with uh jim is we'll make sure
you're all aware of this what the
schedule is and when we're going to be
doing it and what we're going to be
doing it on so you can prepare if you
want
so we'll have that
ready for everybody
uh hopefully uh before the weekend
any questions mr chairman yes if i may
do what is our next scheduled
meeting
and oh they're going to ask me these
hard questions huh
um
i just want to make sure i have my
calendar tony my my
trusted assistant
assistant
yep
that number rings a bell
tuesday the 5th
i don't see it in here so tuesday
february 15th
there's a more more accurate email uh
you got it
all right hearings are going to be on
the 15th
okay then we'll we'll uh
we have this session with the speaker
after that and then
we'll we'll take up the execs and
that'll there'll be a lot i mean we do
we're doing like
five six seven hearings a day we'll do
the execs we're gonna be doing like 20 a
day
they're gonna be they're gonna be quick
so
let's get ready for that and no big deal
i don't think yes representative power
uh sure
yes please okay
thank you mr chair so my question is
with regard to the scheduled hearing for
february 15th do you expect that there's
a lot of bills that we're going to hear
that day
and it's scheduled to i think the last
one is scheduled for three
four four four
and there may be an additional bill as
well do you expect that will execute any
bills on that day no
i don't expect it but
it's gonna be a long day
don't expect that we're gonna get out of
here in a half day and and
so you know uh
we we've been sharing this room with two
other
committees and that's why we haven't
been able to get in here
two or three days a week
and uh and bang our bills out
the other committees are essentially
done now
so that's why we're now we're playing
catch up
and uh
so are there any other dates besides the
15th
no not right today
but maybe by tonight there will be and
i'll share them
okay with all of you
i've thought of an analogy
to illustrate the difference between
recycling and compost
you could think of me as being recycling
my friend trip
is compost
i don't get it do you care to expand
upon that in some way that
what's that
but i don't have a master's degree
or a doctorate
okay this has been published uh the
bills we're going to be hearing
next tuesday
uh
hb 1026
1068.
you all got this by an email
12 38
12 68 12 89
13 33 and 1667. they're going to be
i'm going to be honest with you there's
going to be a couple of tough bills in
that we're going to be looking at i
saved the i did save the best for last
so there's going to be a couple of tough
ones in there
and i just ask you to be professional
and
well just to go through them
there are some that you're probably not
going to want to tackle i don't either
but we still got to do it
all right thank you very much
adjourned for the day
thank you
so jim i'll share those dates with you
asap
there was nobody here
sure i have not had the chance to
contact my husband before that majority
report oh yes sir can i send it to you
myself when i get home sure okay
i couldn't i didn't get to find it yet
if i would have sent
yes
you're supposed to say beautiful
i'm sorry about that
oh
you got a minute or two hey
this evening thank you a minute or
can't even move two
and what we'll do is
we'll bring up a bill that we've had the
hearing on
and i'll ask for a motion
and
we're going to start it on
22nd 27th
23rd
well you know how executive session goes
right
is that what you were asking or just
when we're gonna do it
i would say
pay attention to your health first we
can get a substitute
yeah i'm going to
schedule them
oh we're going to schedule them yeah let
us know yeah
this there's one there's a couple
already scheduled uh tony has 22nd and
23rd
but we didn't put the number we were
going to do in that so
we can do a whole lot they're often very
quick 22 and 23.
23 is
94. but it could be morning you want us
you want us to try to stay away from
the uh
20 what day is bad for you
yeah i'm not going to be here
oh that's right
so
all right well you've got a minute you
can stay you know
yeah
a to allow them to speak
but we're going to allow everybody to
speak we always do
but
we're going to get a buzzer timer
buzzer type of logo
heavy groove
where do we get that from go home and
get one or they have them no
don't buy
it you'll call it
once you call it has um
stephen's missing get the loudest one
you can
that way it's not you they're looking at
it's welcome buzzes to shut me off
they know they have a problem there's a
problem with the email about the lagging
but they said
just put out whatever you got at the
time
and forget about the mess don't worry
about it
include the blue sheet
um
and if you said don't worry about it
why is it making us worry about the
scheduling on that bill for votes
no this is uh the ones that they
call in and they check off i support or
i don't support right and you get it
like 22 kind of
opposed
yeah
and i said to him i said you know
this this business here adds confusion
because
we've had reports this morning there
were two
and four duplicates you know
um and they say and youtube was flagged
listen to this
they were flagged on youtube yesterday
well you're gonna enjoy this youtube was
flagged
probably health and human services
you know what ash burger uh
is it's an
ashburg or is it like a uh monsoon
no yeah yeah it's like that it's a
down syndrome light you know
okay so when the artificial intelligence
deciphered the language you're talking
about
a learning disability yes
and they were talking about it
um
and but when the artificial intelligence
said
uh okay i know what you think
you want to get an asperger you know
and
believe it or not they had to fight that
and not in order not to get shut down on
youtube
and um
so
the anybody that testifies has to be
testifying distinctly and clearly that
is one of the issues
all right see because you can't say hey
you're doing public housing right
i can't say that to him yeah well he
said himself
but anyways let me finish this
let me finish this
um
green sheets you know what the green
tree said
are the green treats these things here
that's green yeah okay
they got to be in in timely manner and
correct
and i've been doing pretty good
um
okay members in the room like
representatives
should be addressed first they should
get their chance to speak first they're
coming to testify yes yes because they
have to go to other hearings that's
right that's where i've always been okay
um but yes i make the
um
the orange badge people testify last
they don't recommend that no really oh
no because then the last thing that
the
hearing people have to hear what the
people at home have to hear
is how they
perceive the bill well they're opposed
to support
so
you can do it two ways
he said you could put them in there and
shuffle up the cards and don't do
anything and what comes out comes out
or you can put them in there right after
the representatives
get them out of the way
that way
the people that come in to testify
can do that and then they testify on
three minutes or two minutes
yeah i mean that is
exactly opposite of what they told us at
the start of the year
they wanted to
be more
polite and responsible for our citizens
and get them up first they want they
want yeah they want you to be polite
but uh
the apparently they're running into
problems where
other people are late for meetings and
can't get there and whatever it is i'm a
good soldier i'll do whatever members in
the room should be addressed
first
then lobbyist then public that's what
they said
um this is from paul the minority
reports can't leave that day to submit
the report
what
well
if you say
what mike oh can you oh
you